and welcome welcome welcome everyone to
another speed Chess Championship match
our final quarter finals of the 2019
event and it's it's without any further
ado this is what most the people have
been waiting for right it's a car
Nakamura the 1 seed overall versus the
the young upstart if you will the rising
star from Poland young Christophe Duda
Robert welcome in buddy well I would say
thanks for having me because you start
off like John Oliver with your welcome
welcome welcome but you know what point
do we stop calling John Christophe due
to the young upstart and just start
calling him a almost top-10 player in
the world he's nearly twenty seven sixty
in classical chess
we know his prowess and speed chess
championship format after he beat serve
a cardiac and Alexander Gerst joke last
year of course a card Nakamura is become
of the mighty beast here the one that
everybody is trying to catch so I'm
really excited for this matchup Danny
I'll tell you we'll stop calling them
the young upstart once he has a little
bit of facial hair that'll be the
that'll be the benchmark once he once he
has a little bit of facial hair
no jokes aside obviously he's considered
the young upstart because of the fact
that he sort of burst on the scene you
know roughly about 18 months ago and
he's been on a rocket star trajectory
ever since but as you said he's going up
against the car Nakamura and this is a
guy that hardly needs an introduction at
all not just to the online chess and
streaming community but in the speech
Chess Championship format here on chefs
calm he is kind of the man to beat right
he is he is the guy that everyone's
gunning for the one seat for a reason
he's he's won himself a speed chess
championship before and been in the
finals every single year so as we look
at those numbers it's hard to even hard
to even know which to highlight more so
so let's dive into the the numbers that
actually give us a little bit more
discussion here because I want to get
smarter Hess's predictions or smarter
Hess's breakdown of the smarter chess
review in terms of how these two guys
stack up well you know smarter chess
predicts the numbers predict Nakamura
being about 70% favorite I know you
think that it's even higher
I'm kind of agreeing with you there I
think that his online prowess is
undeniable he is the number one Blitz
rated player in the world and we talked
about this touched upon it yesterday in
our grad chest or comms route even if a
car over the board is number one it's in
blitz rating we all think that Magnus
Carlsen the best bliss player in the
world
however Magnus is not playing in the
speed Chess Championship which means to
all of us as a car is event to win
although yonkers subdued that is the
upset specialist I do think he has a
fighting chance although he is a heavy
underdog something like I'd give him 20%
chance to win yeah I mean I'd say the
30% that smarter chess gives him is
about a fighters chance right it's about
a puncher's chance and that might be
about as good as he's gonna get right
and not to say that he may not make a
move early I think we'll dive into what
we think as far as where does he need to
strike how and when obviously we know
that Hikaru Nakamura even if some
consider Magnus the best blitz player in
the world I think Hikaru is still
considered by many the best bullet
player and even in matches that he'd
lost a Magnus here in the SCC Hikaru
Ricardo did quite well in the bullets so
I think that if you're gone kristef Duda
you want to strike early and there we
have the percentages that remain for all
of our remaining participants if you
will right you see young Christopher
Duda over there in the eighth seat and
let's go ahead and bring up our bracket
remind everybody where we stand
currently in the format because yan
depandi ah she awaits the winner of
today's match
he's already sitting there pretty in the
semi-finals and of course a lot of
people expecting as we said Hakkar
Nakamura to be the face that joins him
but that's why the game is played right
if it was a foregone conclusion Robert
we wouldn't be here we wouldn't be
sitting next to each other and we
wouldn't be about to start our final
speech has championship quarterfinal the
2019 season we have our players with us
the car doesn't look too tired there
looks a little bit a little bit groggy
but maybe maybe he'll be again going
soon young Chris stuff looks looks ready
to roll and as we get set I want to
welcome in already almost 3000 of you
across our multiple streaming platforms
no matter
where you're tuning in thanks for making
this features championship and chess TV
part of your day will be following all
of the chat rooms live and thanks for
being here so we are moments away from
the games beginning we already have
active chat rooms across everywhere and
right as I say that I think the games
just begun okay so there you go we have
liftoff right no more no more no more
tomfoolery no more ballyhoo here we go
we have 9 of 3 and D for now this is ok
I was just gonna start out how do you
approach this if you're Ricardo do you
play your vintage sort of blitz bullet
repertoire you've become a cup known for
right the g3 is the B threes and the
hick are not good more a dub system I
feel like they should just rename it
right
no and hey Karl wants to play some
mainline stuff against against JKD well
you said no tomfoolery I was thinking no
hikaru foolery in the opening this far
because he is playing some mainline
stuff principle chess in the center
rather than playing as you said b3 g3
fee and ketamine bishops and then
figuring the rest out later and you know
we saw the pre-match interviews with the
players hit card Nakamura has great
respect for young Krista Duda and of
course young Christophe Duda has great
respect for Cara Nakamura and I think
we're seeing that his very first game
because Hikaru is the biggest favorite
when it gets to the quicker time trip
the quickest time controls in fact in
the bullet and JKD has proven himself to
be an absolutely worthy Challenger every
SEC match he's played in a car made a
point of noting that JKD can go on tilt
and he did so against Wesley so and in
this game right now well I mean what
happened on the d5 what let's back up
and see what happened on the d5 we had a
move a two-unit
a now slip he took 195 into the pot yeah
but what happened there it must have
been a mouse slit and he's already kind
of shaking his head I think he had was
he was planning on click click here and
maybe he clicked clicked here right
remember some people prefer the drag
move some people like to click click
when they move
III could use a little bit of both
honestly I kind of a little bounce
around ish
my with my move styles but maybe the
risk of click-click is if you go quickly
here Robert and you click here and then
click here that's what happens right
rather than an actual drag but naca is
normally a dragger so and I you know I
know that cuz we see him on a lot of
streams so very shocking to see a mouse
slip from the favorite here and that
that could be that could be just a very
quick way to go down oh one here right
he just he just down a piece here I'll
move 13 yeah you don't see hick our
mouseland very frequently yeah he's not
playing from his typical location right
right so i wonder if part of it since
he's playing from new york rather than
from Florida or wherever in the world he
is usually playing from I wonder if he's
a different mouse today or something
like that but this is a very bad start
for a car and of course you know
Christophe needs to end this game you
cannot I was gonna say now Picaro comes
back and wins this game who is it really
his head start for right I see crazy
coffee man in the chat saying hey Carver
first click click so maybe I'm wrong I
mean I know that coffee watches a lot of
hikaru streams as well so maybe and
again it sounds very weird this is an
interesting storyline I wasn't expecting
us to dive into you Robert are you a
clicker or a dragger right what are you
into Robert click or drag I'm I don't
really think about it like that
I guess I'm a clicker right no I mean
everybody has a style I think and and it
and it really depends um shout out to
all the love and support were already
getting here I'm I don't know but I'll
be oh no as Hakkar was down a piece if
you're just joining us there was a mouse
slip on move eight from the American and
that's why why we stand where we do her
he's just down a piece but he is up a
minute on time and hikaru more than
anybody else in the world knows how to
mix things up knows how to be
resourceful
especially in blitz where he trusts his
skills and anytime scrabble over anybody
so meaning I'm not surprised he didn't
resign like I'm not not surprised he
also probably wants to get to the
quicker time patrols so I heating up
some of the match clock is probably not
a bad strategy and that's a good point I
didn't think about that he gets to shake
it off right and now I talking Taylor
Swift but he gets to just like say okay
I just did a terrible mouse that I'm
obviously frustrated with myself having
done that because he knows that he
really can't afford to
just hand y'all cursive due to some
games right younger dude is so strong we
keep talking about this the UK just say
here's a free point let me come back and
turn the beat you of course it car was
capable of doing so but it's not what
you want when you're playing the you
know nearly twenty seven sixty
classically rated Jonker subdued oh one
of the top 15 players in the world
jedidah henry ii in the chess TV chat
he's saying he wants to lodge a
complaint from with the people who
scheduled this during the same time as
the grand chests were finals that
complaint should the other organizers
not us no I'm getting Hikaru is a very
very busy guy and when he did not
qualify for the GCT finals this date
opened up and we had to take it because
honestly it's very difficult to find
opportunities to schedule in events but
I stick with us watch the show both of
those events are going right now on
chess comm you can also watch the grand
Chester over at our sister channel
twitch.tv slash chess comm events it's
being covered right now by I am levy
Rosman and GM Roulin Cruiser Broussard's
preserves pursuers bruisers I was gonna
say well Danny why might hit car knuckle
where would be so busy isn't there a
daily question that you wanted to ask
yeah in fact I'd love to queue that as
soon as we're ready because those of you
who are huge fans of Hikaru Nakamura or
even if you're just a casual fan of wait
wait wait wait wait is that gorgeous you
just went back the piece his Queen be
fine okay five oh he looked up okay but
Hikaru announced in his public discord
that he was flying to make an appearance
in a major HBO series we don't know what
that was I don't even know if it's
fiction or nonfiction I don't know if it
involves dragons and Game of Thrones
spin-offs or you know futuristic you
know utopian you know government
suppressed worlds like Watchmen all I
know is I want to know what the world
thinks if it karma Nakamura is gonna
make an appearance on any HBO show ok
chess Bane knows ok classic all right I
want to know what you think so this is
gonna be a fun daily question I hope to
see everyone involved use the hash tag
speech yes you can let us know here in
any chatroom depending on where you want
to watch from but let us know on Twitter
so that we can feature your feature your
Twitter handle let us know and give us a
good reason why would he be in Watchmen
if you know the character
why would he be in Westworld why would
he be in Roberts favorite show berry
very underrated but Curb Your Enthusiasm
is coming back to HBO I love berry
so know let us know your thoughts well
I'll give you joint thoughts on the
Berlin yeah I was gonna say well you
give us your thoughts on what HBO show
Hakkar Nakamura might be appearing on
it's the Berlin a choice that you would
make when you're down at peace well
here's the thing I think if you're a car
Nakamura you forget the fact that you're
down a point right now because the only
reason you lost that first game was due
to a mouse slip again while the live
game is going I'm just gonna show on the
analysis board exactly what happened it
was move 8 an unexplainable Knight takes
d5 here rather than pawn takes d5 which
is the main theory must have just been a
click click Mouse slip where you
accidentally clicked here and then
clicked here so that is why we are where
we stand back to the current game hey
Cara Nakamura is down at one point in
the match it's a lot of theory right now
I can say that about the Berlin for sure
and right now we're in a position where
let's talk about some of the strategic
elements here at Black has these doubled
pawns in the C file which makes in a
pure pawn endgame getting a passed pawn
difficult however with this rook on e6
that rook can swing from flank to flank
it can go over to b6 to poke the b2 on
it can go back over to g6 at the right
moment if necessary and look at this
rook onion on d3 hitting the g3 pawn now
of course why is gonna play a move like
King f2 eventually perhaps you can play
h4 and decide if you wanna play g4 so
you have flexibility from both sides
here which makes the game so complicated
the pawn on e5 for now is a strength it
restricts blacks pieces so h4 for white
makes a lot of sense just to avoid any
kind of g5 threats there he played at
age 4 to stop chief odd because you
haven't actually had a clear and very
potent threat of the g3 pawn hanging in
many variations
yeah and now this moves c4 by a car I
really like because it holds back the
Queen side pawns as you already
highlighted b2 as a potential target but
it also opens up the c5 square for
business if you ever remove your knight
from the center which could be I mean
honestly if I'm just evaluating Berlin
positions this is what I would take his
black
yeah for sure it's one of these
double-edged it's that double-edged the
same way some sharp Sicilians all right
that's where tactics are flying from
side to side here is just like which
side is going to come up with a concrete
plan and many strategic mistakes are
actually possible for example playing
the move b7 to b5 may be a good idea at
some moment but in other times it's just
too soon and actually just like creates
a problem with your structure on the
Queen side and the best piece on the
board is as many for it takes the bishop
square from c5 it covers you know g3 it
you know just protects c3 if black does
go b5 before or something like that so I
think just as many force so powerful and
watch out for some kind of native six or
ninety six threats if the situation
arises where that's a possibility and
instead well jiggy says I'm gonna move
my work away from a1 so let me close
down the Queen side and yeah I like
white here one thing I will note is how
fast JK DS playing especially right on
cue as we see one of the quotes from the
young Christophe Duda we catch up with
all the players before these matches and
ask them interview questions and you can
see that do disrespect for her karo
online is is of the highest order right
and and and I'm saying that because of
how quickly he's playing on the clock
right dudas seems to be making a
concerted effort he did last game two
when he car blunder piece he's like I'm
not gonna let you swindle me in time
pressure right not now Hikaru not now
not this way right so look at that he's
up on the clock against Nakamura which
is just not something you see every day
he's also just has a tremendously good
position because hey look what he cars
been doing he's in swing his rooks by
kind of back and forth and if you look
at the kingside position here you could
play g4 they bring your king to g3 and
just you know white is making progress
and black is just shuffling at this
point and I mean I just don't see a
concrete plan for black and white I see
many different plans another idea
it's like rook d2 and trade off one pair
of rooks suggesting if his rook on d5 is
kind of a nuisance so they play Brooke D
to try to take over the D file he likes
your plan here comes the king up to g3 I
think g4 came g3 rookie three check and
be met by Brooke f3 yep and you're
making you make a great point I really
like the way this was going for black
and I and I said so I mean if I was
evaluating the position back on
III but I guess I underestimated that
while this optically looked good and we
talked about the open file here the
problem is where were you going from
here right and it turned out black
didn't have enough improving moves
whereas white still has many moves to
make as we've seen here slowly expand on
the kingside kind of push black back
which is where dude is headed now so
take account I was going to say he
couldn't play King g3 actually and then
your father f3 because there was Bishop
h4 check at the end I'm gonna show that
on the analysis for a great point so I I
thought I thought he would play King's
you 31 because of check here but then
Roberts went Bishop h4 check overloads
the King and if you back up I just
grabbed the pawn okay I didn't see that
but that means the car was probably
gonna draw now I I don't know that that
trade on h6 did it really improve whites
winning chances kind of shaking his head
like what did I just do so maybe still
does have winning chances well the thing
is if you go after the f7 pawn right
with me rook d7 white can you just go
rook f6 and then say your East six point
is you're already in the danger of
worrying about g5 and a lot of positions
if your rook isn't guarding it yeah
breaking through and pushing Harry just
it looks like a terrible endgame for
black at the very least you look at the
Queen side that four-on-three that we
talked about in the Berlin structure is
useless and creating a passed pawn
especially with rooks off the board so
that's the thing even if you lose the f7
pawns and Brooks get traded Black's not
even really up a pawn and that's the sad
part about having double pawns and you
know I treat all pawns equally but dull
pawns and end games are not very good
rigged up sticks and you're cruising
rook f6 there's no way to deal with h6
and and keep your eye on f7 cuz that
fades coming yeah chances uh which the e
pawn and create some sort of time
scramble counter play but the e pawn you
you know you can go for but I thought
was to bring my King back to f4 okay
just haven't checked to follow and then
the whole queen sized chances may be
something like rook of one here to cut
the ax file and then you know try to
make something magical happened yeah
unfortunately makes not happening in
this one the same Disneyland
now this is just magical place on earth
rookie 7 she's not magic Oh like you
leave that place your wallet that that's
very true yeah this is just the King
just Corral's the pawn by itself and so
the white rook can just start going
lawnmower on the seventh rank and just
taking care of all those the grass there
all those pawns nice this is just all
right this is this has been an
impressive start from JKD now again the
first one I think was just purely hit
carro beating himself no real debate on
that right but that game was a start to
finish
hey Cara might not want to visit the
Berlin again right yeah that was not a
good showing by him and that was mean
yeah played a very good game I think a
car would admit that of course there's
gonna be some frustration on her car's
car saying you know I could have done
things better but all credit to dude oh
does a very well-played game we saw in
the class well game we'd be impressed
and so right now dude oh sorry go ahead
no we talked about that this would need
to be the storyline right for those of
you just joining us let's remind you of
what the pre match predictions were our
smarter chess stats had young Chris of
Duda at about a 30% underdog if you will
right and but we said you know as you
looked at those breakdowns the five one
three one one one if he's gonna need if
he's gonna prove those stats wrong and
pull the upset you got to get a reverse
score there in five one instead of five
and a half three and a half Nakamura
I think dude has got to come out of this
portion up a couple games as the time
controls get faster and right now he's
on pace for doing that right yeah you
definitely cannot afford to go into the
bullet portion with the deficit right we
know that car is the better bullet
player although Yonkers dude is a great
bullet player and especially with
increment rather than just straight one
owe him better chances but you're
definitely right that Duda needs to make
his mark early he needs to frustrate hit
car ooh
because hey car was somebody as due to
himself credit he said the guy just
knows how to put his pieces on great
square that sounds like so basically
right oh he doesn't know but that's very
hard to do is to play extremely
precisely and extremely quickly that
combination is deadly in speechless
championships oh and we talked about
that is the fast
the faster the time control need more
coffee apparently don't twist it the
more intuition takes over right the more
you have to have those instincts and
those very just the brutal calculation
skills and I think that you know right
after Magnus of his generation you would
probably put a car Nakamura as maybe
number two in terms of just pure
intuition pure calculation and that's
why he is the beast he is in blitz right
and I think that that's why dude is very
complimentary of him and and why you
know we expect him to be the favorite
but right now young Chris stuff sporting
a new hairdo was I saw someone in chat
say earlier also sport and uh Gordon a
two-game lead shout out to Jules cheat
amazing support yesterday we appreciate
all the love and the the subscriptions
and the the dough knows we've been
getting with our G Grantchester coverage
and appreciate everyone who's here and
all the chat rooms no matter where
you're watching we've already got almost
six thousand people people want to see
Nakamura play blitz I've learned I've
learned that that's something people
want to see Robert they like that
awesome might want to see Duda play come
on you'll give the guy some credit to
know but you're absolutely right it car
was made a huge name for himself of
course for is over the board skills and
accomplishments but as well as being a
popular streamer here so on the internet
you know he of course is very popular
but right now he really is work cut out
for him because the black side of this
Sicilian I would not mind his position
at all for Jake eighteen I see four here
just you know get I thought nicely for
instead of taking his Ikey talk tend not
to like these positions from the black
sign when you take on be three gears
white these double pawns but those pawns
are mobile right that pawns going to be
for another next one might go to a five
yeah I thought I might go to be five and
you're under your pawns in a very clear
way like a very simple way I I agree
totally and I've I've played too many
bad dragons as black to like that either
and so I'm gonna review the opening real
quick as we were talking storyline here
but we started out with a knight or foot
ultimately kind of transposed here with
this a four move going away from a
knight or young Kristoff's says okay
well I'll go into a dragon now that I
know you're not gonna play Yugoslav
attack which is from a practical point
of view kind of interesting right the
reason you don't play the dragon Robert
is because we don't like Yugoslav
attacks right this was an interesting
sort of footwork there he says you're
not gonna play this so now I will now
all go in for a dragon but it didn't
throw a car
off here and the main structure Roberts
highlighting is that taking b3 is just
so often an improvement for white the
move he was gonna suggest was Knight c4
right Robert to try to get the disrepair
yeah I just think that you know the
double pawns are appealing for white
more so than they are as like a
potential target for black to take
advantage of so I was definitely suggest
9 c4 there and well he didn't play it so
now we get this position where White has
taken over space in the center that
Bishop on b3 you have to wonder has it
wandered too far because rook a3 is
coming in the near future and that
Bishop is quickly running out of squares
as the main point everybody is if you
get rook a3 let's say some random move
and this Bishop goes to c4 you're not
trading here you're moving the bishop
and then playing b3 exactly yeah that's
okay this is little C if your card goes
for a plane like this it seems kind of
straightforward to me Noro given those
eyes there that's it that's a car number
7 he's skeptical of his opponents plan
yeah he is quizzically looking at me
like wait a second and yawn Christophe
kind of gives a scratch he's like I
don't know we'll find out here we'll
find out that bishop has a future and
you know rook a3 we I guess this is a
position where you need to calculate
concretely because Bishop c4 you need to
figure out what is the precise Square
for your bishop to move to because I'm
sure that you can't just move to any
square from the e2 and trying to trap
the bishop there has to be so he started
with Bishop g4 like that that's a sneaky
way to do it right well yeah it's very
trapping admission yes now this is a
direct threat rook a3 and b3 will just
trap the bishop on c4 so black can't
play d4 it's um home but then yours be
gonna be down upon so clear that's not
what you're aiming for
what else can black do here it's so boy
you almost have to sack the D pawn right
but the problem is that just even then
what are you gonna do go to d5 and let
me trade right I have an idea can you
play Queen e7 their index videos for ya
he's hitting before but 92 quickly found
by Hikaru a new threat 94 + b3 arises
yes bishop is just not doing well over
here if you take on c1 here you get the
f4 pawn or you tip with a knight on see
oh that's nice the night takes and the
bishop is trapped on the spot wow what a
concept
rook takes Knight takes Bishop c4 b3 and
then you have to go d4 we've been
talking about this d4 bush at some point
in these lines that bishops getting trap
you play d4 just give up upon and hope
that uh things are not too bad but this
is just positionally good for white I
think it all comes back to this Knight
takes b3 decision for me h5 how does
that help just push back three kind of
like a desperate you uh need to get a
tempo a part of the issue that was black
head I used the g5 as well trying to
undermine the e5 pawn but now g5 is way
worse than it was before cuz h5 hangs
and every variation so this idea g5 to
undermine e5 I wonder if he missed that
let's back up real quick and show that
on the old analysis board this move g5
is kind of a useful shot to keep in mind
you've got two attackers here yeah maybe
this was his chance because what right
now while the rooks are kind of staring
each other down the bishop is sort of
still alive right of black like has has
a chance to create a mess as long as
there's other tension in the position
that you can't just go out of your way
to trap the bishop although on that no
rookie three might have been totally
possible because if the trade happens
you kind of still run out of squares
here right but the Bishop c4 with a 92
means there's actually night hangings
who's been done nothing right yeah and a
lot of these positions again the point
is that you're gonna take care with
tempo an e5 is falling so I'm with you
maybe g5 Oh lookey to actually play
chief five now so whether he missed it
the first time or decided he doesn't
care about the h-bond he has found at
the second time yes and now all of a
sudden you know the problem I was trying
to highlight is the h5 pawn mu man I
captured right now but that pawn h5
feels like it's just hanging in certain
variations so like if I go g3 to
reinforce my structure and not allow you
to just kind of collapse it because see
some kind of force line there I'm a
dissipating so G takes f 4 here it looks
like the best move right G takes up 4
gains a tempos
you can't just take b3 and with a piece
so GF for Bishop for me just you know
your Bishop getting trapped so let me
just sacrifice it on a4 then take on e5
and claim compensation oh you and Bishop
the car was taking his time with that
Bishop wants to make sure he guards ePHI
before he goes for v3 extremely
instructive though still going to be
trapped yeah so Hikaru just playing
rookie you want what a calm move yeah
like she takes a confident tall tall
drink of water there I think knowing
that his opponent is under 20 seconds
and probably still getting his Bishop
trap though is b3 finally ob3 agus queen
takes before gives black some
compensation for that Bishop that's
going to be lost but it just it feels
like just the correct move awarded here
should be lights out and should get hit
car knocking more on the scoreboard and
he's doing a great job right now I'm
using his time but that's something that
we've criticized the players in
classical chess the last few days but
the car spent a little bit when Bishop
takes h5 realized hey I don't even need
to track this I'm gonna go check
mate this Baron black King on g8 I was
calculating b3 Queen before and you
could probably still win a piece in that
line but I think this is this is likely
the more accurate approach yeah cuz
they'd actually be three still traps the
bishop you to check first Queen you
three check take away the d3 Square and
then you throw rookie three right that's
how you do it
rook on the elevator lifted to g3 in
fact you can even play it now because
you might be threatening sacrifices in a
lot of positions yeah he does it yep
here comes rook takes g7 and then Queen
g3 and Bishop h6 lights out Bishop g5
and if you Queen was away Knight 9066
check is gonna be a oh you love it when
you find moves like Knight take these
thick they can see it it's light up so I
was gonna say cube if six is probably
just good enough but Bishop takes f7
works as well yeah he's winning that
Queen just like that hey Cara nakamura
is gonna get on the board here yeah I
mean I don't agree with yours young
Christopher laying this out like
to me given the fact that he wants to
get as many longtime control games as
possible although again okay we're
adding a little bit of storyline maybe
young Christopher isn't as afraid of her
car when bullet as as the rest of us
think he should be right I mean it is
the increment bullet as you've said it's
one thing that makes the SCC what it is
it's it's it's as high quality bullet as
you can get real chess matters when you
add that increment it's not just brutal
flagging yeah I think that always helps
the you know the the underdog yeah
totally
and well I guess young Chris off he
might not consider himself that heavy of
an underdog he did express that he is
absolutely underdog
the car not the Moors the favorite but
he you know he's a confident player you
should be confident great chess these
days he was the runner-up in the Hamburg
feed a Grand Prix event so you know he's
he's gonna hit the best shape chest
shape of his life so why not just play
us out a little bit see if he can make a
miracle happen and we'll have a deep on
already dawn a dancin on the d1 square
no not enough you're still you're still
running into h7 on the next move and
remember Ben Sylvan and the chess TV
chat says Duda knows no fear but car
Nakamura when it comes to the SCC says
abandon all hope ye who enter here this
is my game right he gets on the board
and we'll see if he can keep it up hit
card enough the mores only lost to
Magnus Carlsen in speeches championships
so back to the Berlin if you're just
joining us everyone this was game two
and honestly it was probably the best
game so far for either player young
Christopher really outplayed Hikaru Game
one was a mouse slip by Nakamura that
ultimately had him lose so this is
interesting and we're in the exact same
line so guess what everyone if you
missed Game two and you just got here
no worries you're not seeing any you
haven't seen anything new yet this is
exactly what happened in Game two
we'll see where Hikaru tries to improve
Robert yeah and sure is certainly
curious to see how it car plans to
improve his chances because the last
time around it seemed like young Krishna
didn't do all that much he played
natural moves I mean this wasn't having
h4 was played this is the exact game hey
Carlo played rook d3 young
kristef late h4 in game 2 hick auto
played c4 but it didn't slow down
White's eventual kind of expansion over
here on the kingside advancing and and
dominating but hey Carl must feel he had
a clear improvement cuz there was
something about the facial expression he
gave there Robert I know you were
reading the board I was reading hikaru
and I think when he missed Knight f6
check he felt like he could have held
that and I think he was just a little
frustrated with the way he calculated
the rook ending I don't know I really
didn't like his position throughout but
I do appreciate you reading you know the
picture book while I'm reading the book
with words so I got my kids the book
with no pictures by BJ Novak great if
you're a get it go I don't get anything
boy BJ Novak book with no pictures
great stuff it was really for me so I
could stop reading pictures well you you
are the absolute world expert in reading
it Cara Nakamura facial expressions you
even have a well you know speaking of
which the car was on the board the car
was happy I got both facial expressions
next to me today I planned for them both
to make appearances the problem is I
could never see if it if it's working
yeah it's working and I can see oh look
at that night takes g3 but to analyze
what happened miscalculation
well he played King h2 into the h4 this
game and this was a who flinches first
it was actually a young Kristoff and
this might be where you called him up
start earlier talk about his
youthfulness rice could be one of those
moments where youthfulness backfires
because he felt like he was the one who
needed to change the move order position
and I think it's still a pretty good
position for white but something you
know I feels like it's got a bit wrong
for you on Christoph because now the e5
pawn is more vulnerable the 94 looks
very good and this exchange of pawns g4g
that was gonna help just super nice move
because there was a threat of rookie a
rookie a winning the rook nice now you
know the King will run a c6 and the pawn
on c4 yeah protects the rook on d3 very
very good call there nobody I don't know
that I mean you really think this is
still good for white I think that I
think you made the right call when you
said maybe this is where youth is
showing because h4 was played in Game
two
buddy and young Christopher went on to
win see for only then did he bring the
king of the major difference here
h4 stopped the move g5 and this game he
didn't play it he played the move king
h2 and Hikaru didn't look back he
strikes with g5 trades on g3 I'm already
feeling a little bit more confident than
Hikaru can hold this one
maybe not win but I mean you know this
is if 'if I've traits for f7 the active
Brooks and the knight in the center to
me just like this doesn't look like as
good as what young Krista I've gotten
game to I mean I've so root G to g7 here
looks like a an annoying threat with the
c7 point hanging but perhaps black just
has a draw by checking a bunch of times
that seems to be the way out here
because it's getting to be kind of
dangerous territory after root G to g7
because you can't afford to let these
rooks just just absolutely destroy the
seventh rank so rookie to check probably
and then followed up actually don't see
a clear-cut draw there I mean you might
overestimating White's position I feel
like you are but I've been wrong before
twice hmm-hmm
rook g2 g7 rook d2 checked okay whose
rook c8 similar idea okay
Hikaru not quite sure I think black
might wonder if you have more the
problem is not just that the pawn Falls
but everybody that goes with it the
Czechs and the house as they say I chose
to g7 rather than whoopsie because that
worked d7 yeah you wanted rookie to
right
no I wasn't my king but I thought now
rook d7 as possible so that you stopped
me from following your c7 pot yeah but
what young christophe Duda is relying on
here is the H pawn is an outside passed
pawn in an endgame where black again
will have a harder time creating a
passed pawn because those pawns are
doubled over there on the Queen side so
he's gonna rip da check okay abroad
greens worked at d4 and then the nice
infectivity six after rook D for the
black rook can come into e2 I guess the
main thing for white is you
to move this fish of robber from my h4
to d4 right you'd love to put the bishop
on a central square where it defends and
helps the H pawn run up the board at the
same time so White's pieces are just
lacking optimal sort of setup right and
I think before is you know you want to
share that square in some ways between
the bishop and the rook right before
you're hitting the c4 pawn if you're 96
Bishop g3 comes in and I can track back
to the ship g3 rookie - you take d6 we
trade I guess what I thought was maybe
the second-ranked rook might be a cumin
up but okay b5 is nice if you the main
thing about holding c4 is if you know we
talked about imaginary chess for white
if you could play imaginary just for
black and just put this rook on e2
you're in a fantastic fantastic shape
well you also can put your knight on c5
into d3 as well - huh yeah yeah so I
think a four here just to get rid of
some of the queenside pawns might be an
option because I don't know him Bishop
f2 saying you know please take me your
rookie to idea though he just kind of
walked into it so he likes his h-bomb
that's really what yeah he wants to push
the H point if he plays H 496 the rook
moves maybe White's fast enough
here he comes yeah there's the trouble
h5 is next so this was the right play by
do - though I think to go all-in on the
H pawn and hope the rook and Knight
can't coordinate in time although h5 be
4 4 5 love that move h5 b4 and suddenly
c3 is the fastest pawned yeah it just
goes to show that again we always talk
about this quality of pawns more in the
Quan Dee sacrifice that be pawn to get
the C pawn sprung free here DeCaro
giving me I'm gonna look up in the air
and pretend I'm confirming variations
I've already calculated it gars played
very well in this endgame I'm surprised
that impressed he went back for that
Berlin that looks so bad although again
it was due to who changed the game so
something tells me we haven't seen the
last of that variation Robert that both
sides won't be won't be flinching yet
right because I still believe in it from
the white side of course the car was
still believing it from the black side
he's done the preparation he's on all
the
work to figure out how this position
will go and right now he's spending time
which again this is the right moment to
spend time this is a absolutely critical
moment here trying to figure out it's a
pond by pawn move race right the H pond
the C pawn trying to figure out he goes
kini v is is that the best move I'm not
sure but rook f7 he you know was played
and now the rook looks a little better
to me and f7 they did on f6 yeah he only
did it for this line here right because
the purpose of bringing the take tonight
Danny you take the knight in h6 and you
can't catch the pawn here car was
looking up in the air he's trying to
recalculate those variations okay the
problem everyone is if rook takes King
takes h6 rook moves h7 you get back but
then Bishop d4 and it's lights out but
you know what's funny Robert maybe you
have enough pawns over here I think you
do have enough yeah you have King e4
qingtian you get over here Carter that's
those that is deep in calculation Hikaru
look right there he was calculating that
line and I'm not sure it was gonna pay
off but something like this you get like
c5 and B foreign key I actually think
black was in time wow what a smart idea
though by young Christoph here king of
trade that night oh wow
on the edge of the board you can't play
Knight f6 cuz Bishop d4 King e6 and you
win the night oh my gosh so young Chris
I was you know he I was looking at this
pawn running down the h-file he should
take that pawn and have at it
and let me trap your knight it shows the
dominance but you know what over at the
crazy part of this line is now now
you're looking at variations where the
night's gonna fall
oh no Saxon exchange yeah that's way
smarter right you know that was
resourceful right there yeah Lucy 7 but
he immediately picks up the c3 pawn with
a fork on e4 okay he goes for it yeah
but you take a 7 here so you're gonna
keep your a pawn so this should probably
probably be a draw yeah yeah just play
eight okay before you can go Asian
because maybe one check
so before it's possible here not a four
also works you'll bring the King to be
four you know okay dude it just stops
that with a three but still likely a
draw now I know we started touch on it
and then they and then they kind of big
our attention with some awesome moves
but you know what should do to do I
think you push this on because you're
the only one who can win but overall I
mean what is your strategy as far as
time controls if you were if you were
Judas coach what would you tell him
about these kind of scenarios pre-match
like hey dude if you get these types of
endings that could take like five
minutes off the clock maybe consider
taking a draw in getting another blitz
game would that be your advice as a
coach or would you say no dude push it
if you have it normally because he's
playing the card Nakamura I would say
get as many of the longtime control
games as possible and that's not to say
that hit car was weak in this time - of
course he's an absent monster but then I
think about him like how did young
Christophe do to make it to the
semi-finals last year he won his bullet
segments against Sergei Kuryakin yeah I
was in aggressive excetera shook yeah
and he won those by you know very clear
margin so it wasn't like he won by one
game he ended up coming back in the
match down like three games like waiting
for bullet games at the end of his magic
and Sasha for sure right you know I
think it's good not to have a defeatist
attitude of hey if I'm you know down a
game going into bullet I'm gonna lose
this match so actually I applaud him for
just playing out these positions that he
wouldn't use playing classical chess
yep yeah because you know the
psychological risk of having a
predetermined mindset I'm afraid of
bullet I'm afraid of bullet is then when
you get to bullet you've already sort of
beaten yourself right and so you don't I
would say from a chess mindset I would
agree with you even though I think
originally I spend a lot of time
thinking that if you're Duda you want to
make your move in the blitz time
controls you don't want to have the
psychological mindset that you can't
beat somebody in any time control right
unless you're me and you just know you
can't win in any time control you're
hoping to not get adopted that's it
thank you but but most people don't have
that mindset and the point is I think
that Duda makes the right play if he's
trying to push but but I I don't know I
mean I think we say that it's the right
kind of sports mindset Robert I do think
there is something like if you were
sitting down pre-match and let's say the
SEC was like like all you focused on
that week I think you would have
discussions hey you're gonna reach these
types of endings types of endings where
yes you have a to result position
normally you would push OTB but if
you're gonna lose five minutes on the
clock like consider
the situation right I do think that's a
worthy discussion and we've talked to a
lot of the players over these years you
know guys like grow shook and Hikaru I
think have done a very good job having
that kind of meta meta strategy in there
you know they're thinking in the
gamesmanship of what they want to do in
those cases as we've talked to them at
interviews no absolutely and it's
important and young Kristof yeah I don't
know exactly what he's thinking but I I
do feel like he's a very confident
player these days he's earned it and
he's playing pretty well I would say
that last game was Hikaru was the one
who was better throughout that game so
that was actually even Hikaru won the
game with whitey car one was also pretty
good but that game he just played Andrew
I was very impressed by the quality of
his play throughout it really comes back
to two moves from the last game one move
was this not playing h4 not working line
and the game before that from young
Chris not playing Knight takes b3 and
seven nights before and that's chest
jargon but what I'm essentially saying
is I felt that young Christoph in
critical moments has chosen now to two
straight games sub optimal strategies
whereas Hikaru has really turned on the
Jets losing the first two games to feel
like he's the one who is gaining
strength and gaining momentum and this
is a very critical game right now agreed
agreed agreed
got to give diamond member been sold in
some more love despite purposely
misspelling my name he gave us a band
name the wrench in the machine I like it
and he says you realize this commentary
is worth hours of coaching right thank
you thank you for your support there
Diamond member Ben Stilton and we we
love having him active chess TV chat
today all right we have an alibi in
Sicilian in fact I just checked at the
chest commie Co and I was literally
gonna say it's kind of a delayed alla
pin and that apparently is what it's
actually called delayed alla pin
Sicilian because that's weird I know
that but yeah this is a delay Taliban
structure if we go to the analysis board
real quick everyone is basically defined
as you rather than opening the center
and it opens the Sicilian which we've
already seen you purposely are making
sure that when you get d4 you can take
back with a pawn so it's almost like
playing for sort of a traditional
Spanish structure right if you look at
how white has developed the pieces here
it's kind of like you had a really lopez
the night maneuvers the bishop maneuvers
and you've created this structure where
eventually you want to get the center
but you're hoping to keep it rather than
trade it and so this the structure is is
uh I don't want to say unorthodox very
mainline but it's not not open Sicilians
for sure and now in the live position
Robert are we about to get everyone's
favorite bad opening you might French
but not quite the bishop is already
outside to put the structure over here
on g6 yeah it's more like a Carroll con
this Wainwright for black I like blacks
position actually yeah it is the more I
look at it it's uh if you put this
Bishop on see it I'd changed my mind
well very important point is that white
is not in time like beef for us that's
officially seven here
you can't played before is there's a pin
along the a file which is yep extremely
important to know I've been surgery I
thought you were even saying d4 but
there was a pin on the depot deep on as
well because of the Queen trade and on
the island on the a file right he's
playing c4 now saying alright I've kind
of closed down the Queen side so I'll
take on c2 and now it doesn't look like
a French but a pretty good version for
black because you trade off the light
squared bishop and you can eventually
finite a five to be three or Knight b6
Queen eight for tried trade these Queens
off and white is not able to break open
the Queen side because as soon as you
play me like b3 then black takes over
the vulnerable light squares on the side
of the board and it's just it just looks
this looks nice for black I don't see an
attack coming for white usually you move
your knight in play f4 f5 is what hit
car is trying for but yeah black can
also try to make progress in the Queen
side some moment like moving the night
from b6 like b5 one I need to be three
put a five before to crash through on
the Queen side so that's what this is
all about right now is which side can
open up the position favorably and do
normally you would say that white and
this type of attack with that for a five
really loves it especially if you know
somehow this king is over here then that
the potential of that goes way up I
think the biggest issue here is yeah
this is a very nice move Bishop h4 I
like that is that Hikaru can't really
just closed his eyes and push and expect
that that'll just that'll just
automatically give an advantage because
King is safe even if you achieve f5 and
black also has ways to continue to
improve her here on the Queen side well
look at this move King age three yeah
while he is doing active with that King
look at going baby get it to g4 before
he reminds me of the legendary Hikaru h3
facial expression which is actually an
emote in our in our channel there if you
want to use it
the legendary h3 okay now he fives
opened up for business somehow that
trade has me liking White's chances more
than I did before the the newly-created
target on e6 even with pieces in the way
is something you're worried about
actually almost is blundered an exchange
I say Bishop d6 here but Knight f7 is a
fork that looks pretty frustrating to
deal with yep what happened Robert we
talk a lot about pawn structures in our
show and and often the base pawn is so
critical to maintaining a chain because
if you move it you're always creating
positional weaknesses without exception
and so in this case that pawn moves
which means E 6 is gonna become open and
I worry about that I mean it makes sense
because you know what dude was thinking
you're thinking are you really bringing
your king to age 3 like right I'm gonna
open up this side of the board and
eventually slide this lady back and
you're gonna regret this little journey
you went on but Carter doesn't care yeah
the thing is the King on h3 isn't that
weak it's hard to bring pieces into it
attack it and now he's gonna put g4 I
think and then bring the knight back out
from H 1 into g3 and Wow would we
believe in this no but I don't see wait
for black to do anything to punish
White's adventurousness whether I
believe in it or not I believe in the
power of chess pay and the gifted subs
thank you so much that's awesome mystery
gift subs loot use your new emotes if
you have them get your hair car Nakamura
facial expressions out and thank you so
much yes pay all right we've got uh we
got you know we've got we've got a crazy
active show here today we've got across
all of our platforms
we've got almost 9,500 viewers more than
that a lot of people tuning in here
thanks for being with us this is a huge
event right now obviously we've got the
one the only hit car Nakamura trying to
show why he's the number one seed in the
speeches championship 97 is a fork oh oh
and Duda shook his head like oh thank
God he didn't see it
Wow that I didn't see the first either
using 97 like what are you talking about
cuz the night he walked off the Queen's
protection it was a blunder that neither
saw coming analysis for to the Batcave
Knight to d7 was not possible and this
is what we call mutual blindness and
chess where both players just forget
that attack I mean this was just this
was not it this was not a choice by gar
this was just a straight-up blunder this
just wins on the spot with east six
falling yeah I don't want to you know
harp on this too much wow we had we had
the same situation in Gary versus Duda
right there were numerous games where
there is mutual blindness between those
two criteria altum Utley went home in
that match
yep I mean so you don't want that to be
the case if you're her car Nakamura you
don't want to miss your chances while
you have them well he went for it you
have to give him credit he puts King on
h3 yeah pushing his King side pawns he
said I don't care about the weak squares
that you could infiltrate on the Queen
side because you're not actually making
that much progress look what he's done
that's by the way this before was
awesome yeah like the e6 pawn is pinned
he could trade and when he 6 and guess
who walked there King Day ch3 it lives
to tell about it
I thought you're gonna Nigel goes all
the way to h6 yes yeah quoting the
legendary game Nigel short yon Tim and
seriously Google that right now go to
chess games calm one of the best chess
games of all time Nigel short yawn Tim
and the legendary King walk
Queenie six ok Queen f2 does the trick
as well because the e7 pawn is still
okay I think 26 was better but hey Carl
is gonna win this one anyway look at the
clock young Christopher has five seconds
two minutes for Hikaru we're gonna have
a tied match most likely after this game
yep sort of an epic blunder the Hikaru
might be about to make but otherwise now
yeah it looks pretty hard to me also you
meet yourself somehow like your rook f6
Queen e4 and don't get why I was just
about to say watch out for Queen h1 hey
Carlos sees it though and says you got
nothing kid Brooke f8 game over Red
Rover send you on krysta fright over we
have a tight match you know what else we
have coming up the puzzle about World
Chess Championship
guess who committed to playing that hey
Cara Nakamura I say play you know what
we gotta say in that when we do
commentary overt what solve sure this is
not a traditional World Chess
Championship this is the first of what
we hope to become an annual and forever
thing the qualification rules if you're
happen to be watching anybody who does
puzzle rush on chess calm can qualify
just record yourself doing it submit it
with a 35 plus score and we will deem
you but basically worthy of playing in
the qualification tournament that will
ultimately fill out our bracket of 16
guys like a car Nakamura Maxine Bosch a
magrav ali reza firoozeh
to name a few big names are in the event
already as seated players but anyway
there you go
hey wow oh look at those two guys
apparently we will have commentary there
to look at how they just do that image
together real quick we look good there
buddy working out no I've been working
on my chest commentary muscles though
you know what you're wearing that same
shirt from that picture I am oh my gosh
[Laughter]
all right so now okay now we've got now
we've got the same game as game to you
okay
fun fact everybody for just joining us
young Christopher due to one game two
and was up to Oh in this match and this
was the exact position on the board so
what does he call have ready to improve
here I don't know I'm gonna back up real
quick cuz now we've seen in game four
Yann Christophe played the move King g2
here on the analysis board are sorry
King h2 and Hikaru struck nicely with g5
and then Knight takes g3 overwhelming
the bishop Hikaru ultimately went on to
draw that game with black pretty easily
in the game was where Yong Christophe
has played h4 to stop g5 he seems to be
getting an edge kind of like our live
position now Robert so the question is
why is he car
for this line if he's already been
outplayed pretty badly once in it I
think that this time he blinked first
right the last time we I mean the same
thing here you could have a g5 he should
have played g5 and I cannot comprehend
why Yonkers have to dress like king in
shoe before age 4 it just doesn't make
sense
ya know it was really a you caught no
dude you said it in that game you said
this is where the youth and inexperience
was paying off that young Chris stuff
kind of over thought the situation right
instead of just throwing it back in a
car when saying dude show me your
improvement he improved and ultimately
it didn't pay off right because a g5 was
good for black I thought you know looks
way better than this does
I'm looking at this position I know
young Chris ups the one spending time
but the elements that I see white can
start pushing pawns in the Kings side at
some moment yeah and that is going to
frustrate a car that here come to five
is such a thorn in black side because
the would have four just protects
it the only way you can really get rid
of his I'm playing f6 is a moment I
would play rook a to d1 here to try to
trade off this active rook and then say
well if you let me was gonna save white
why not go for g4 I've stopped okay G
for g4 9 H for King g3 your night is
almost wrapped but there's g5 again
there's I have you for me Tom Passat you
dirty dog forcing me to go French okay
let's show let's show that g5 anchoring
and then if I um pissant the knight gets
out and hits e5 that's classic Hess
tricking Danny wasn't my fault you treat
yourself
don't you talk don't you shut your mouth
when you're talking to me well then
you're gonna you already make fun of me
in front of 10,000 people on a regular
basis you know there's not enough no it
hurts me to see you upset okay rook d1
if okay rook b5 was the other option to
hit me too but I guess just what rook d2
was gonna stop that no big hit me oh oh
okay he just went from g5 he's trying to
undermine the protection of the yep on
e5 but but on passant on poisson happens
that's a good bumper sticker office on
happens that's actually awesome we
should do that super sir dept going on
chest comp
that'll be pretty sweet but this nor
else the Swedes is not oniy for its back
to where it belongs
yeah I like it control control control
control in again I keep saying this I
know I'm just repeating myself but the
four on three on the Queen set is not
really that advantageous for black
because of the don't pause and here
comes the white king he learned for me
Carson dear King was going up in there
we and there it is I'll raise you one
don't tell John Locke what he can't do
it comes the king yeah again and and I
know this game isn't over young
Christopher is also down a minute by the
way we should highlight that but this is
this is not the Berlin you want to keep
getting if you're Hikaru now on the
other hand from a practical point of
view Berlin's take a lot of time off
that off the total clock I don't know
maybe he's just trying to milk the five
minute portion here as we see we have
about thirty eight minutes left there in
your lower left corner so Hikaru giving
himself the favorite not in the faster
time controls maybe he likes the Berlin
even if he's groveling I haven't enjoyed
watching his positions from the black
side of Berlin but he definitely has
faith in his preparation but look at
this position I mean this is just great
for doof know you do display an eye tips
it's just good good boy and what really
highlights the problem of having to
double pawns you play tonight c5 is
black and I just simply trade nights you
just look in the endgame where white
will try to push the Jeep on up the
board and get one of those pawns has a
clear pass on pass I actually really
like your playing because you can go all
the way to g6 and undermine the
protection of the night yeah it's what I
do if you won't go night c5 I'll just
push my Jeep on to get after your night
anyway and just looks fantastic for Duda
and you can see also the practical
dynamics starting to favor Duda because
he car was time advantages is much lower
than it was there comes chief for g5
yeah he does it okay that's a creative
solution rook d5 offers the fix
everybody you're saying if you trade I
get to undoes two pawns and then maybe
push D for myself let's say we do I mean
if we go to the back hand for that let's
do a second here to the Batcave
take on d5 it's very forcing line rook
d5 cd5
yup Knight f6 check yep kake's pawn
takes f6 c4 I take you on d4 you take
with an eye no kini for like am I going
just win your queen side pawn to my king
huh yeah that's it a good point I mean
yeah Hikaru kind of making a making a
smudge face that's a rare one that's a
car loan number 19 to smudge smudge
she had out to platinum member spirit
rapper in the chess TV chat who came up
with another one a bumper sticker that
says 4q with a knight on it I love it so
at one point I came with an idea of a
bunch of t-shirt chest t-shirts and Eric
my partner Jessica comes to Danni we
don't run a t-shirt company and that was
the end of that discussion
hey but merch you know was always good
um anyway all right so 97 has played the
problem for Hakkar oh is that the the G
pawn is still running and he's shaking
his head this is again this is just not
a great if you're playing to get
victories here in the 5 minute it's a
karo the Berlin has got to go right
I mean you he drew that one game cuz
dude I messed up but I'll be surprised
if we see this again now yeah II 6 ok he
was 90 of 60 I was 86 is a spring for
the Jeep on right you often want the
pawn that's furthest away from the rest
of the action yeah so if you put e6000
and let's say hit car took on e6 and
then Duda takes the King the Jeep on now
is the outside passed pawn which will
take all the blacks resources to stop it
from becoming a new queen and then white
will switch flags and go over to the
Queen side here kt5 I think is now 30
King d6 and King D for I think maybe the
reason e6 didn't come was because of 93
check kind of 6o in the light position
oh it's over
no but 94 check oh sweet the full works
but no it's waiting for white king of
596 King g5 you got my he sees it hikaru
he's like ah that hurt look at this
trick everybody young Christopher he's
flexing man he just wants to go flex
Zach
the bishop King comes next hashtag post
Malone Jeff I'm you didn't see coming
well I cannot believe you just quoted
post Malone here dude I woke my kid to a
post Malone concert don't judge my
parenting it was he puts on a good show
I'm not but you know thank you also to
swear nine times here saying Danny
mentioned Robert SR my two all-time
favorite commentators wow thank you
man dude it did just flex on that but
again okay the the Berlin what's the
match strategy here we know here car who
has played Berlin in a lot of over the
board chest as well the Berlin for the
both sides but everyone remembers the
epic MVL Hikaru match from sec a couple
years ago where they played like what
like seventeen Berlin's or something and
it was all deep deep theory and and for
those who say the speech just doesn't
contribute to high quality League games
they're just wrong right there's a lot
of theory being played here because
these guys take these matches seriously
but I just I don't like it from a
practical choice and I and I appreciate
dude a--'s willingness for the fight
he's just gonna play main line theory is
white and he you know he's two out of
three two and a half out of three now on
the white side of the Berlin no he's
he's - he lost the game right no he drew
that game remember it was two and a half
out of three cuz the car didn't win yeah
trapped inside of them yep so it's it's
- and F out of three four dude in the
Berlin I think it's time to go away from
that I agree at all and I think that
hikaru is trying to neutralize young
Christoph and I think when we get into
the quicker time controls he's
definitely going to stop playing the
Berlin and start playing sharper things
where he feels like he is the edge
because there's a few minutes for do to
start calculating things right now in
this position I think that black has a
good position especially in opening
because look at how much control black
has over many advanced squares before is
now under attack now he has control of
the semi open D file and he could play
very simple moves he can play move like
a four at some point they can also play
Queen c7 root d8 decide later where that
Bishop on c8 belongs the for that plan I
like how you say decide later because I
think that's instructive for those
looking for those accidental Robert has
teaching moments they happen a lot the
the lines that are open on both sides of
the board mean to actually
east six and a six are always available
for the bishop and so if you can
prioritize developing other pieces and
coordinating to put pressure on other
critical squares you don't have to
always go back to classical chess
principles of getting that Bishop off
the back rank just to connect the rook
so accidental teaching Robert has moment
brought to you by Robert has kind of
brought to them by me but yeah go ahead
oh I see you taking credit I'm like the
GM translator you say things
I'm Michael you know how Obama had that
angry translator key and Peele yeah I'm
like you're I'm like your chess
translator to Obama's two key appeals
angry Obama okay I can they can dig that
we should do a show like that but you
say something and then I step in and get
real inappropriate wait isn't that this
show that's our producer there in the
background yeah anyway thanks for being
with us we've got about eleven thousand
of you right now just in English and we
are also covering every speech s
championship match in multiple languages
I think we even have Polish today Robert
in honor of young Christopher due to
being one of the participants
well the Polish team can translate what
young cursive just did because ninety
eight walks right into ninety three and
Down Goes the c5 square and shaking his
head he knows it let's back up to the
analysis board and show everybody what
just happens so this position ninety
eight it's a weird subtle one move
blunder because the point is ninety
three is not a threat as long as this
night can go to d7 and just guard c5 yep
but as soon as the night does one false
step to e8 you don't have to ask a carro
twice to spot a tactic and c5 is falling
and with c5 the entire position feels
like it's collapsing right that's just
one pawn is that well now my knight is
jumping into c5 so your Bishop on a6 is
gonna be miserable if you play C for to
start with I can just take your pawn on
c4 and then put my name to c5 anyway and
not good not good at all yeah that's a
that's a big moment it's gonna be a big
win for Recaro because again it if I if
I was a car as coach flipping the
flipping the sights here for a minute
rather than advice would give to do die
would say that as long as he keeps us
close and the faster time controls he'll
be fine so and of course we'll catch up
with the players as we always do after
the match and get their thoughts on what
their match strategies were Wow okay I
guess you think if you took on c5 with a
knight he was gonna play Knight d4 so
that's why he took with the Bishop on c5
I would have preferred to take with a
knight of course but due to had some
tricks up his sleeve apparently you can
tell I'm not confident in that meetings
you think if I take with the night you
had a trick yeah maybe 94 I was saying
exactly like that instead he takes the
bishop and is their compensation down
this semi-open CFO can i play a four to
kick your night away from b3 now and
maybe it's not so bad for due to after
all it's not good but you might not be
the worst position possible well the
problem is he's also down two minutes on
the clock now to go with it and I think
he's he's undeniably worse the question
is will you find it will he find some
compensation this Knight can't even move
to a-1 okay he goes here but I think
he'll go to a 2 and B 4 anyway my idea
was a 1 C 2 and B 4 but this is better
for Hikaru cuz it also will protect
he'll play Bishop b4 and then when the
night comes here he's protecting yeah he
does it ah nice and yeah you take 19
before just Bishop e7 the c3 pawn still
yes well we all know yeah night before
Bishop d7 you probably have to settle on
rook c1 mister guard the pawn yeah hey
Cara does that maybe okay now the
question is when did we put a pony on d5
okay I like this idea Robert he's
playing Bishop g2 I think he wants
Knight d2 to open up the bishop and
Benny's gonna put the knight on d5
okay good buying it no no I'm definitely
buying it and I think that what is
better 92 is a very good move
I'm into that and I just I'm not sure
how much better white is because look at
the right one a3 as soon as you go 95
and ivory remind Bishop to f8 the pawn
a3 does feel a little bit queen of me
say no I was just highlighting that I
agree
so it feels like black is much better
than I would have expected him to be
considering that he just lost a pawn and
he moves ago now rook c5 that's a nice
move again you're just trying to both
over protect d5 everyone and prepare to
double rooks hitting blacks target over
here on c3 White's weakness okay I still
like 92 and I liked it before cuz the
main thing is when the 95 trade happens
I open up the e4 square Accardo has gone
in for for making Harry a real wizard
over here on the H file but now what
good the good news is he can play Queen
B 2 or d2 and Queen c7 is my Bishop h3
kickin your rook off the C file because
otherwise the pressure on the c3 pawn is
too much but with the inclusion Bishop
h3 has a possibility that I'm not
allowing black to pile up the pressure
yeah I like that
Duda sees it moves the rook off of that
c8 square don't you move Knight d5 now I
like it I love it in fact now that the
Brooks on c5 if 95 takes and bakes we
have pins coming on d4 because of the e
pawn okay he doesn't do it Carter
playing very patiently in this
particular game yeah he also is a good
deal of time so he doesn't need to force
any of the issues here the problem with
playing to patiently sometimes is that
you allow your opponent to get a pretty
good set up and then you're not able to
you know really take a pawn extra pawn
and promote that into more of an
advanced official h3 here you can play
just kick this rook off of the CH square
that I love that I play just swing over
to the Kings side yeah he does it but
here comes the d5 square he wants to
ponies on it well that's really nice
actually I think you have to get
aggressive on the Kings side for Duda
you had to put like H 5 H 4 you have a
dark squared Bishop that's not doing
anything yeah so get that Bishop to h6
play age for so I'm breaking open the
Kings side hello 7 is a similar idea
right let me just
we go aggressive and now they have three
square if you allow me to a knife three
check and I take off your fee and kind
of mission of your King feels a lot
weaker yeah it's a good point to your
highlighting using the one Bishop the
white doesn't have right the dark
squares are the main issue if you can
make something of that the problem is if
you're Duda you're down a lot on the
clock and so Hikaru as in typical
fashion gets the kind of use time when
it matters most to find accurate moves
he doesn't want to let you work on f3
but now that needs to right that's the
thing is when you put make them of an h2
you're stopping your opponent's threat
of putting your piece on a bad square
next one Bishop c8 while you but Bishop
CH ago night h3 CH I like that a lot
bishops yet you're also threading which
would be three that's a move
we'd be three you're hitting a three now
that looks like a hanging pawn right
yeah and it's one of those awkward hang
upon that's like a computer fight weary
but see for the Queen get trapped don't
trap your queen with c4 did you just go
all the Reza 1483 Brooke a1 Queen b3
rook b1 lights out lady oh he doesn't
see it I think it might attract the
Queen to the Batcave real quick see for
real Queen
ten seconds and counting down right now
let's do a little line I don't know how
you stop that alright well we'll come
back to the live game but seriously that
that was an interesting find maybe he
caught Oh missed it may not matter
because of the time pressure that dude
has gotten himself in here yeah so
there's rook anyone still trapped the
Queen rook ever get one Queen b3 roofie
oh wait he looks to the site at Coral
Sea sub let's look see we can see it
what I think it does trap the Queen but
then he realizes that young Chris is
going Bishop takes d5 they take on b3
and you actually have a lot of
compensation there you really do that
yes is frustrating to deal with okay
he's going words I was just gonna say
let's go to the Batcave but we don't
have to because they're about to do it
he sacrificed the Queen we're seeing it
on the board I honestly think this is
easier play for black yeah no that was
one of those weird accidental blunders
and
with only 10 seconds young Kristoff's
still has a chance a pawn is really fast
now he's got two connected patches wow
if this one gets away from mcaro that
would be a huge turnaround just like
rook c4 and take on d4 right just ok
trace the rooks so he's clearly banking
on his a pawn to provoke over the mate
check is complete f6 and then the
eighth-ranked in fact now you can even
are you winning the race with d5 a 3d 6
a 2 you get d7 with tempo yeah maybe
just as good if not better
now e5 blocks up the bishop scope oh I
thought it would play you 5 there
look at Chris op he you know he's losing
this anyway but at least he's super
resourceful yeah ok Queen b5 should be
good enough this point yeah baby right
away you take the bishop right I think
we'd be 5 right that's very true right 3
Queen b3 the eighth point is providing
some conversation but your queen takes
b5 here means a pawn can't push but look
at a car we're getting down to 10
seconds it's a pure just cards
connection is is out of control
he's at 1 bar oh no you better get back
on no way oh my gosh that's the hotel
Internet we're in saqqara right now we
almost never see him not playing with
the red wall and the fan in his hair
he's clearly on the road oh my god
Cara's connection is gone and we have
drama everybody this might be the first
time we've ever seen her car of playing
on a bad connection
Wow and if he is playing from New York I
guess I'm sorry for taking up all the
good connection in New York but hey then
young Chris up in her car switched
places yes cool young Chris stuff is
smiling those that he stole one there
Wow I mean what to make of this also
what's going on now because the game
hasn't started so I guess the cars and
cars back online yet but does that
what's the regulations for that okay of
course we trying to give the players as
if there's a disconnect we pretty much
give them as much time as they need to
get back but if they lose a game in two
process of the disconnection the game
stands so basically that result will
stand and if you disconnect even if you
was offline for 10 or 15 minutes we
would do everything we could to get them
back but if you lose a game because of a
bad connection the result stands Oh
totally makes sense right connection is
up to you it's your responsibility right
I don't think anyone would dispute that
it's unfortunate of course and yeah
honestly if this comes down to a coin
flip that kind of game right there is oh
wow we see the the facepalm it's maxed
from our solo chatter over there on
mixer oh wait no again that's not mixer
I forget no one's on mixer that's right
so the bad thing right now is a car
mixer but ninja just you know but the
bad thing is two cars down two games
right now the good thing for him is that
the two games he's down is one he was
completely winning and the first game of
the match he blundered a piece on the
mouse lips so it's like my quality of
play he's not like my quality of play
he's he's even and doing fine right and
again you just hope it's not it's not a
continued storyline right we see he's
still even now only back to a two bar
connection yeah but he might turn into
Bruce Banner and nobody likes a car when
he's mad right no one likes a car oh
what'd he say great you face him it's
like you would your hangry you're
literally like that Snickers commercial
where you turn into a diva you know that
we got a mercy I am NOT like a diva so
don't over emphasize me and my hungry
stays I'm not hungry right now I had a
salad before we started this comic I'm
not telling you you don't know that
information that's personal is it like a
cranberry salad with like nuts no no
okay well we've lost the car right now
on webcam he is still connected to chest
comms live server from what we can see
we will work to get him back right now
we've got what would we have here we've
got a weird and awkward opening
control yeah this is not a good way to
rebound after a disconnected loss
sometimes when you when you lose a game
like that you're frustrated you play you
play the next opening kind of without
thinking
hashtag guilty but this is not a good
recipe here this is bad structure stuff
yeah the thing is though it's not really
easy to pierce through it and that's
always the annoying thing because I've
had both sides of this position type of
position before and b5 and know that I'm
not into that move that feels like
you're opening things up or not
apparently but is that Fischer 183 going
to be trapped but how do how does way
make progress now that you've closed the
position now how does white make
progress you're asking me a real
question here yes I am to play it do you
like King edge to eventually try to
Bishop g4 and push your Jeep on to start
opening up the King side oh I had an
idea and I think it's wisely should we
quarrel right
I think White's progress was to move the
rook and bring the knight to b1 and trap
the bishop he was but now Queen B - two
straps - Oh Queen B - a four I go a
three I think this is terrible for black
yeah a3 bishop back before no not before
you take it take it
Queen B - a4 a3 you back up and we just
blow this thing open party on the B file
yeah this is a bad opening and again
that happens I think again it's kind of
a tilt opening that's what you want to
avoid if you're Hikaru right is getting
into a tilt situation where you're kind
of frustrated cuz you have a bad
connection although right now look his
connection has stabilized if your
maracas if you're looking at that four
bar situation on the on the screen there
next to his username so he has
stabilized this connection right now
which is a good sign maybe we'll have
him back on on camera soon a for now
okay it's gonna be the same problem for
Hikaru yeah because now white is gonna
rip open the Queen side let's get with
the rook on b3 yeah then play play
Bishop a5 put a four just I don't care
about my pawn since I'm being okay I've
rook on the b7 square it's just a
solution you definitely
no but again it's not surprised we keep
saying it's a bad opening it is a bad
opening like this is not a recipe for
playing high level SCC chess and a car
can get away a lot of times with this
type of approach and like Bullitt right
but this is I think I think he he
switched away from the Berlin and right
now he's trying to find that next black
opening he's gonna use against Duda see
for Robert yet he hasn't found it yet
it's too early to get desperate and this
is not purely desperate or this is a
Little Gym and opening that is
objectively better for white but the
more you sort of jockey for space and
just let the pieces kind of tell the
tale the position and not too many
trades generally happen the prom for
black is when trades happen like this
and at Rugby seven comes looking on yay
okay he went rook a three so we're gonna
open the position for his pieces I like
for p7 but for kiiis probably even
better and look at that dark square
Bishop is terrible look at the pony h4
it's vulnerable yep just good news for
doctors and I know and I think a car
will recover from that but what I meant
is that the tilt based on what just
happened with the disconnect right it's
too early in the match situation to tilt
I agree with you like he's only down two
games and like you said from a chess
perspective Hikaru has played just fine
right
he's lost a game that he was winning
because of a disconnect and he lost the
game because of a mouse slit but it
doesn't matter the scoreboard is what
matters and right now you don't want to
take a bad approach strategically
because of those kind of unfortunate
circumstances yep but this is just right
doing absolutely nothing you can you may
play Queen a rook a seven Queen B seven
and yeah this is not ideal that ideal is
a scientific term I coined title my
autobiography
I'm just looking this position and it
comes from kind of different openings
right there is the opening play in this
game the modern the gergan easy but it
also happens in certain D for openings
like the heart thought Horowitz is that
it's called where you know sometimes
blacks just totally cramped on the
queenside and white just eventually
breaks through and
it's all bad news over there so yeah
Queen B seven rook a seven pretty
natural moves to come here why can't
waste like Bishop g4 to try to take this
night off via five and get the H for
pawn to fall this is like this is just
such a painful position and as smarter
chess a wise man once said even a good
connection can't save a bad opening the
Karma may have fixed his connection but
he's still in trouble here rook a seven
bad news
Bueller broke a seven-night before I
mean Hikaru needs to just kind of milk
this one to like gather his kind of
nerves right because at this point this
is this is the gonna be is this the
first ever free game deficit Hikaru has
ever faced to someone who's not named
Magnus Carlsen
that's a great question hopefully
smarter chess canister that yeah we're
gonna check into that hey Carter doesn't
go down 3 games in speech Chess
Championship matches very often but it's
it's we could be about to see it and the
recovery needs to it we used to head
into mainline all right well Lucy 7 I'm
expecting night before here no it's a
big blunder because Bishop takes e5 oh I
was kidding lol let's show it on the
analysis board ok that works but right
here that would be how I lose a winning
position night before because it's
unstoppable that I win ce6
and then you take here with a discovery
on my queen and I lose although it's
funny his white position is still so
good you could take and take e5 and
who's better here
just saying but again unnecessary right
the way he's taken the approach to get
two pieces for the rook the c6 pawn is
still a problem and so was the White
team still great white King is a problem
here running a seven queen a1 what's
happening here
flipping the script if this is a rebound
game then brush your shoulders off at
Cara Nakamura cuz jay-z wants his
comeback back yeah yep I don't know
watch out because Queen e1 is absolutely
deadly so you might have to try to make
a draw some out we
I don't hate me but going back to night
before are you seeing
I'm serious white is better in that
position after should be 527 97f take c5
I'm winning c6 and this you disagree you
disagree yeah what is definitely not
better there this is this is a good
queen sack here at the very least black
can play queen g5 after at 65 and have
queen c1 queen of 4 is a draw we gonna
bail out for a draw even by just giving
me your night I'm saying at the very
least and ok that might be at the very
best no all right we're gonna we're
gonna have this argument off air when no
one's watching all right well hey Caro
to his credit has completely turned it
around and look at that look at that
time advantage of two minutes to 30
seconds he's witty now route 61 yeah we
wanted we got made on the dark squares
right yeah buddy calling way villains
rookie 1 91 93 don't even take the night
back
Najee oh wait is this also meat ok this
might also be me okay but Nigeria was
just ending the game oh but Knight g3
there was Queen d8 so I mean that's why
you didn't do it
gosh chess is complicated yeah but it
looks like he's gonna convert on this
one
the fans can't see duty yet but they
will soon we can see him he's a little
bit little bit bit disturbed by how that
one turned around oh look at this T
times you take nobody's night of what
checker than Queen c1 exactly finds it
Hikaru found it too strong he's strong
too fast that was uh well not my
nickname in high school but I'm sure
someone had it you had many nicknames
but that's sadly it was not one okay
maiden 102 is mate dude how did that
turn around seriously that was that was
literally a you said it and now a chat
is quoting you Hikaru is angry you won't
like me when I'm angry
you definitely
we don't want to play hit car when he's
angry yeah that was that is a game dude
is gonna want to forget very soon
because because that did not go as
planned Judah was completely winning let
let's actually bring back the analysis
board real quick when we have a moment
and just just to show why we're we're
kind of so shocked I mean regardless of
my argument that I'll win later with
Robert that night before Queen sac
probably was just fine for white
regardless of that there's no way this
variation where you have the two pieces
for the rook and you've dominated the
whole way should not still be better for
white but even if you don't go Queen c8
Robert or night before like another move
rook a eight anything that just
maintains the bind black is just black
is just groveling here yep just crazy
how quickly and again credit to Hikaru
that he chose a bad opening mid tilt and
what I mean by that was it's not an
insult to a car which he was very
frustrated he's lost the game because of
connection kind of you know struggling
with his camera that although everything
was happening and and he lost that that
that game so he chooses you know this
horrible opening that we criticized
where black has probably clearly worth
starting as early as move ten like these
lines are just not recipes for success
against super GM's like Duda but then he
comes all the way back and eventually
look at this position dude with how did
he out of black win this game yes
absolutely nuts but you know speaking of
tilts and black getting better positions
I mean look at the positions right now I
think a car was what does this open it
they I do not believe in White's
position in the game we're currently
seeing right now
okay I'm back at it I'm focused although
I'm just I'm still shocked that her car
managed to recover from that but he's
still down a game and you're saying as I
look at it now that he seems to still be
kind of choosing tiltable openings yeah
like this is the kind of opening where
he might play it's a much lower rated
opponent saying I'm gonna get
compensation plugins these double e
pawns but get some like young Chris up
do de it just doesn't feel correct just
you can there's so many different
options here right black and black queen
g6 then decide if you want to reroute
your knight to protect the e6
so you can play and move like 98 to c7
if you really want to keep the pawn and
also threatened pawn to e6 to e5 at the
right moment any Knight move from f6
stops white from playing d3 to d4 which
cements that pony's sake so I'm not
buying this I'm really not buying this
ya know it this is a one of those one of
those sacks you make on e6 kind of again
I have used the term before it's kind of
a bullet opening maybe right but this is
Black has plenty of time to really
figure out how to best consolidate with
these TT pawns and I don't think it
should be too hard you've got great
control over the center and as you said
you're just up upon yep no wow so let's
see what is it car going to do here so
you win 98 which I think stops t4i
you've the nine bishop now teaming up in
the square to prevent it yeah and this
is nice because you also open the F file
and you block on the chess TV Chad says
hey Caro hasn't moved a muscle
amazing self-control yeah he's very
stoic right that's really really got his
poker face on that guy oh yeah this is
gonna be good for Judah but Hikaru again
playing quickly up emitted on the clock
already and that's his that's his game
plan that kind of worked out last game
he was worse but managed to hold on and
in time pressure he actually swindled a
victory there yeah and the last game we
understood his opening right it was Full
Tilt mode he's trying to he was just
fighting for a victory to move one and
even if it was a risky opening they
turned out very badly for him you knew
his intentions this game I'm not so sure
maybe he'll get out of this and his
vision will end up being okay
but this ePHI v6 thing that just looked
good from black and he might ultimately
show off his speeches prowess and even
win a game of this nature but it just
doesn't feel like the correct opening
yep this is coming from somebody who
plays many incorrect openings but I was
a closest iliyan player I'm glad you
said it because I was about to talk to
you about that we've talked about this
many times you are a close to sin hater
you've given me so much grief about it
you made me cry when I was
eight years old first of all you were
like 13 at least okay didn't sound that
he better for me didn't make me sound
any better but okay to be fair Robert
was like 2500 when he was 13 so you know
who was really being abused there
alright Bishop to c8 just keep it on the
board there you go
you guard e6 honestly black can consider
taking a five at some point because
ideally white would keep the e file open
to try to apply pressure on the e6 pawn
now I'm not definiteiy gonna be fine but
if it was a queen trade being offered
then black would be happy to swap Queens
as M games look totally Pleasant Oh easy
Janet
okay so human Knight of 6 so you just
trying to get an endgame trade off some
pieces same ie pawn if you take on d6
I'll be able to protect the key
my rook if necessary
so Bishop takes f6 a rook takes f6 five
rook takes f6 Bishop blinds and h6 I
think both are actually fine I think I
think black is still in pretty good
shape yeah I just like the other game
right I want the bishop on h6 right the
bishop on g7 yep that is my extra bishop
in the position I control the dark
square yep on f6 I'm not doing anything
from h6 now I might come to d2 and take
your c3 pawn but I guess it was hoarse
cry tier right I mean we've been saying
black is better for awhile now yeah we
have and he's kind of holding on and I
like this move b3 because if the trade
happens the a file is open right if you
don't maybe maybe I get the B file and
we know what rooks won right compared to
what bishops won that's a new movie
coming you've heard of what women want
what men want
what rooks want so the rooks want open
files and so beat 64 yeah things are
opening up here so Bishop d2 you're
gonna stack the exchange back up you're
a car you could do it I'm wondering
about I think he would have I drove it
was any good but I'll show it Bishop d2
you take here and you end up winning
b7 pawn I think even before d5 would
check I actually think it's good for
white
oops yeah I think I think that was the
idea although actually instead of taking
the rook on anyone you take the pawn to
c3 you just keep the Brooklyn ah that's
a good point yeah though no that could
have been interesting you take here and
not even because you want the rooks you
want d4 with check I'll take everything
yeah okay that might have been a missed
opportunity by Judah just because the I
like your point he didn't have to take
everything but this is still I have a
feeling he car was about to tie the
match like you win that game an opening
choice that was Full Tilt mode he should
have lost if you're just joining us
somehow now he's been on the worse side
of an exchange sac here but no longer I
mean just objectively remove what
happened for the first 30 moves who do
you like in this position white White's
doing fine what is doing well here yeah
because now you look at this position
right we have a from the A through C
files black has an extra pawn there and
why I'm bringing that to our attention
is at some moment black will play b5 and
if you're not careful black but also
played before giving up the b-pawn to
Springfree the seat bone we saw that as
I possibly in that Berlin endgame
several games ago yeah that's something
that might be why for now hey cars
keeping the rooks on the board center
plane truck f1 you've had Brook h1
trying to open up more lines you know
trying to h5 in if there's a right time
for it you should put in chief for g5 if
you can just gain space but right now
it's a bit of back and forth shuffling
here I'm not I'm not sure if either side
really knows what the evaluation is I
mean I thought but I think what one side
knows is he's up two minutes on the
clock right and you're more you poke and
prod and again it's not B it's the
strategy that makes it car is so
dangerous and this stuff that even
earlier like it's not it those aren't
moments we applaud robber but even when
he make like that bad exchange like
black is better after the exchange stack
right but he always plays quickly his
intuition of where to put the pieces as
do to said it's just so high that you
know now he's up on the clock and and
it's gonna pay off even if objectively
he shouldn't win this position yeah but
this b5 move watch out for b4 so you
know if Hikaru can avoid any kind of
passed pawn situation for Duda I think
as you said he's a great chance to win
he's up so much time but do
those 20 seconds and he is a talented
yell its Flair so it's it's something to
keep an eye on here yeah I think white
needs to play Brooke be one to hold
before and then you can move this rook
to e5 without Bishop d2 being a problem
that's true and he goes for it
I like this what about like rook f8
Bishop g7 pawn before any way like to
get the let's get help we're both
predicting moves here let's keep going
all predict not get you predict Duda ok
B 6 a 4 okay nice oh no wrong I say
rookie 5 oh no no okay now B 5 B 5c3
darn it you're smart it this is too hard
if I take a 5 C 3 still see through yeah
okay so Bishop b3 keep the bishop I'm so
good rook takes a 5 ok here comes this
idea was we talked about so long ago and
finally the pawn is every and we talk
about the Berlin okay either R okay six
of rook c5 okay he goes rookie six now
he can go moves he's threatening Brooks
e6 I think Judas plane is extremely well
with them agreed agreed
Bishop c4 it might be a huge threat and
some I think you could play rook c6 and
I think he's worried about Bishop DQ and
he doesn't see another move well Brooks
c6 assaults of rook c8 just trading off
the rooks and saying you know I'm gonna
keep my sponsee three triple rooks okay
if Brooks see a rook c6 there was b5
next but he goes b5 first I think he'll
still go for Brooke c6 at some point
okay Oh first the beep on oh ok 76 whoa
wait look at this he's getting that beep
on isn't he crazy but rooks see sevens
coming no but rook c7 I go Bishop d5 and
you hold everything yep his black
turning this one around dude if he wins
this game given that he's been on on
under 10 seconds here for what seems
like a an hour what a game by Judith b6
is falling he's gonna get e7 but then c2
maybe there's a perpetual yeah I think
there's a perpetual you take e7 c2 and
you check check check a ruski yep you
can never take c2 because your rook
hangs though so Nakamura can't really
win it's a question and that's what
that's why he's taking his time right
now to see if there's any last chance to
win because I think he knows he has a
draw if he plays rook F e7
and he making it one more game in if her
car makes the draw immediately he might
not want another game in this time
control which is white oh look at her
car whose gamesmanship right there he's
very awake ro understand icaro has more
experience in the SCC than anybody else
he's literally made it to the finals all
three years and you know so if anybody
is using the match situation to his
advantage it's in karo and I think
that's exactly what he's dealing Robert
good call so now he's gonna he's gonna
let it sit down he's gonna let it think
and ensure that this is the last
five-minute game and we will be headed
to three minutes yes everybody yep
and here's that repetition we've been
talking about yep he's just waiting a
little bit longer waiting a little bit
longer I'm just worried this connections
gonna go out of someone that would that
would be held that strategy backfires if
you somehow lost that would that would
hurt but no it does not we are headed to
three-minute chess this game will be
aborted they have started but it is
aborted I think at carlow knew exactly
what was happening there and that we are
headed to three minutes chess young
Chris stuff steps up and takes a break
okay karo we can imagine also steps up
and takes a break we'll use our
imagination what's the car doing right
now he takes off those Princess Leia
white headphones shakes his hair in the
wind and says this is the 2019 speech
Chess Championship we'll be right back
and we are back with the 2019 speech as
championship quarterfinal match between
a car Nakamura and young Christophe Duda
and boy we never know what to expect on
these shows Robert sometimes the
underdog does get a lead and that's a
little bit of drama sometimes the
favorite dominates it has us all shocked
sometimes you get a mouse slip and game
won right losses because of
disconnection total drama hair flowing
in the wind Robert you're you go well
it's been a fascinating match thus far
of course Game one was marred by this
horrendous mouse slip where a car at a
normal position of the opening and touch
well grab the Knights of the pawn for
capture lost a piece then he car was
winning in that game against John
Kristoff he end up disconnecting and
losing on time but that's not all young
Chris updo
was just crushing hikaru in that other
game and then let hit car escape and in
fact win that game so we've had players
give each other points that they didn't
really deserve and so this one point
lead for Jonker subdued it's it's been a
toss-up the sort I don't want people to
think that yep Christoph's and playing
much better their car or their cars and
playing with further on Chris I'm doing
giving each other Mutual chances right
now it's a three minute portion and I
got to give props to young Chris up Duda
because well you know of course is in
the situation with the you know when
your opponent disconnects not only is
your opponent kind of flustered you're
also don't really feel good about that
either right nobody likes winning games
in that manner
he has been a good sports and we talked
to him briefly during the intermission
and he's ready to fight and play more
chess yeah and the games are gonna begin
here any second and just so the people
know as the games take off I think
waiting yet there we go we've been
discussing it with DiCaro we tried
multiple times with the camera right now
his connection is unstable for the video
and young Christophe Duda has granted
his permission he he agrees and is not
you know is not worried about her car
not being on camera obviously as Robert
just said it young Christophe wants a
good fight he wants the best chess
possible so we're gonna continue to work
on that Hikaru is looking into some
solutions we will for sure have both
players for interviews regardless of who
wins but if you're just joining us and
many of you yelling at me in the chat
about getting hit carlos camera back on
at the break I'm doing my best I am a
magician a wizard on the level of I
would say Saruman the white but I'm not
capable of fixing internet connections
in New York at the very least I will
Wingardium Leviosa and remind you you
can watch the grand chess to our finals
with international master leve Rosman
over at twitch.tv slash chess club
events thanks for being everybody the
three-minute portion here we go Robert
well the kind of wizard I would have had
you at was a og Neville Longbottom
so I mean first of all higher standards
for yourself thank you I love Neville he
really is the chosen one I will pull
that sword out and cut that head off
that snake okay I mean you're still oh
gee Neville Longbottom we're just scared
of everything and
okay let's let's not do this right now
back to the chess queen needs you so
what we have here is a mirach C vine
structure gone weird and what I mean by
that everybody we want to head over to
the Batcave yeah normally in these types
of structures you actually have a light
square bishop for both sides but it's
actually not a traditional Moroccan bond
this is actually a bola slops keyhole
which means the e-file is open instead
of the C file so that's a small it seems
kind of unnecessary
you know semantics clarification but it
does change a lot because with the C
file open the biggest target is the c4
pawn with the e-file open the biggest
target is typically the e4 pawn and we
see her Cara putting himself in a
position to target that so honestly if I
had to rank who I like better in this
particular type of bolas loss keyhole
right now it's black mainly because
usually the battle Robert and I'm
curious what you think about this maybe
you see it differently
usually the battle is around does black
get enough compensation to end pressure
on e4 before white can get a ton of
pressure on d6 right and start forcing
moves like Bishop FA to defend but right
now black is already ahead the rook is
coming to d8 and I feel like if we're
just giving a slight not hit karo maybe
maybe as one of his better starts to a
game here yeah and one of the critical
questions is can black played Bishop
takes c3 which is exactly why yeah young
Chris I've just played Bishop d4 he's
like I don't even want to give you this
pawn I don't want to calculate do I have
compensation I of the dark square
control in return for a pawn so he plays
B up before I stop that but I agree with
you that it Cara's decision looks
absolutely fine here you know he has
control of many central squares you do
not want to take on c5 any double black
spawns but look at how good that Bishop
is in the dark squares if you end up
taking that nine c5 so yeah before is a
very natural move here but 96 yeah but
yeah I know that's what I was gonna say
is is the the fact that black already
has control over these critical squares
white is what is a Tempe short right you
kind of need Queen d2 and a4 already to
d6 to be a problem you need you need
some more pressure but black is okay now
to be clear doesn't mean that white is
any really any objectively worse it just
mean black has kind of equalized the
clock is probably the biggest thing Duda
might be afraid of at this point down a
minute already
here's a three bit of portion yeah but
its position you know it's pretty close
he is nothing really to worry about just
yet
but as he keeps thinking he keeps
ticking the seconds down here see five
as one was that I would not recommend
that so that came as surprise to me I
was getting that he didn't have too much
to worry about because his position was
so solid like black could attack
anything but as soon as you push this
pawn to c5 now that pawn is sort of a
permanent weakness okay you're gonna
have to deal with no I was just Highland
the pawns were we're well coordinated in
the center white didn't have much to
worry about but now yes you've got the
b7 pawn but I think c5 is as big if not
more of a weakness and and look look out
for Bishop if he plays it before I can
highlight but you heard me start to say
the B word yep
I mean this is just good from black in
this game yep and I white okay Kingi -
you need cover the f3 Square and some of
the holes in your position the Kings
side but where is white going to start
acnes as you point out the b7 pawn is a
backward pawn you can always put
overcome b1 but that's it you're never
actually gonna win that pawn and c5 is
very weak
so perhaps Knight f4 is the means of
training off some of the pieces because
when you have yeah I like that move by
dude oh yeah you have less space less
control trading off what you're just
looking to kind of equalize this one out
although if Hikaru dilly-dally is too
much then all of a sudden perhaps white
can try to press it and move like a 5 e
6 if you're able to get that in it could
be very dangerous and look at this
Bishop e5 move saying you know let me
take over it the leg is he gonna do it
isn't gonna bring the bishop back and go
full battery I like it
c5 pawn problem.the a to pawn also a bit
of an issue
maybe you just go for Bishop yeah Bishop
a1 here and open up that door I mean now
you've got threats at some point and
made on the brain over here
rook c2 okay the problem is - Carter if
you're having a problem for do to hit
car was playing very accurately here at
Duda only has 15 seconds yeah most of
the rook end games and I mean pure work
end game without Queen's and Bishop are
going to be just probably slightly
better for black because the b7 pawn
again is the lone target
so this is why you know hit a car was
would like to trade Queens off the board
but of course yeah I'm Christoph saying
if you ever try to trade Queens he gave
me the long diagonal I'm gonna try to
meet you okay well I like the tickle by
Judah I'm into that well I I mean the
car is the one who's choosing to go back
and forth right now I think yeah but I
mean from dudas perspective with the
time pressure you got to be willing that
rook b3 maybe yeah he finds it you guard
III yep Brett and rook f3 and here comes
me Bishop f6 and just gave me more space
for white in this position black can
play Bishop g7 and trade off the bishops
and that actually might be a wise move
at some point in the near future because
I don't see how black makes progress
otherwise
okay so Bishop c3 just play that
otherwise rook t1 comes o you for ooh a
forward check I'm gonna kh2 ah there's
may tone hae acardo's thinking there if
you can't tell by his face Oh Benny's f6
in a queen of secured Bishop g7 oh you
see that
nice move vacant homes it's over it's 57
is a very nice finish dude is gonna go
down a piece here he just resigns before
Recaro can finish the combination and
nakamura
has tied up the match at five games of
peace here having solved some of his his
connection and mouse slip issues but
Duda I don't expect to to make this easy
here in the three minute portion John
Hughes 2 and the chess TV chat says he
thinks that Karl can play chess solve
quantum mechanics and watch football at
the same time he can never watch
football play chess and was the other
thing stream you can do those yeah it
often does yeah okay so in this position
this is one of these weird weird
lunchable petrov one of my favorite ways
to play it actually something kind of
funky just cuz you get you get something
different rather than all the symmetry
you got the knight on it for hitting d5
which is not just symmetrical a couple
of knights on c3 f3 c 6 and f6
i think black should be doing ok and no
I think blacks fine I'm just I like
these
from a practical perspective it's kind
of funky yeah put you in neutral
territory very earlier you can't rely on
opening preparation and we saw a card
Macklemore try against five-minute
Caruana in the feed HS that Kanpur and
Swiss you put they just subtle h3 move
in a the white side of there's a very
composition you're just trying for
things saying I don't want my opponent
to be able to just blitz out moves based
on you were talking and I wasn't okay I
looked first and look at it okay
everyone if you take the Queen it was
made and now he's guys we Nate you for
free the ban came back that was so
freakin awesome I didn't look at this
move Queen a free oh my gosh honestly
like a year to awesome and the reason
why it's not just a flashy hope chest
yes if you take its bait but you're also
threatening Queen takes c3 and then
Bishop a3 mate and if you do anything
else he just wins the pawn and keeps the
mating attack alive what a move I mean
if you this is one of those moments we
really wish we had a carro on camera
because that was a flippin shot in the
dark right there from Duda that was
nasty
that was so sick we see the chat going
wild chess TV Duda and how could you not
root for a guy who sees me was like
winning that was just so awesome look at
him zoning in there he's about to rick
roll us however we've seen him waste
huge advantages in some of the other
games so he is careful here not like our
output rookie six followed by Brooke a
six and might be three and three like
that just the biggest thing for Duda is
I you know I think he has to speed up
over alright okay obviously it always
sounds like Captain Obvious you have to
play good moves and play them fast
okay thanks but seriously you can't you
can't overthink these early moments
right now he's still down a little bit
on the clock and if he's gonna stay in
this match with a card you've got to
keep the Moot keep the speed up
hey that was sick I was so awesome it
was just like this is why we've watched
chess and some of us still play good
chests not me but you know band man oh
man let me do two of my favourite
players and you know I never rude
against a card not for more when we have
a party that might be the game of the
year so awesome I don't care who wins
this match I'm so happy
let's go oh my god good he plays Queen
83 first of all just how freaking
amazing is that you're threatening mate
and you it's also sound you win you win
upon on a two and keep the attack going
and as we harp on the FAC hey don't let
it car go back in and do this like I got
you baby birds I'm putting Brooke on a
six and then he drops the Queen on a one
and if you take the reason everybody is
93 is double check and mate oh my gosh
that was so freaking awesome
honestly I'm mesmerized by they team
like wins the match anymore like I can
just walk away that was so I was so
awesome in for context you know chess
not calm does these yearly you're Game
of the Year voting like that in fact I'm
working on a video that we're recording
for for YouTube and we're working on our
like top 10 moments of 2019 well guess
what we just have to add to the list
that game fresh that game for sure is
getting it that was awesome I was about
to say if Sam Copeland if somebody's
listening right now daddy thank him to
the list of is always always watching
wow I don't even want to comment on
these anything tell me when this one's
over
that was so sick it was so sick
I advise right now because I have no
words what do you say we need a safe
word the next time that happens let's
try to talk about this chest we went
from like the most exciting position
ever game with zero trades and all the
position is closed oh my it doesn't
matter who you're rooting for in this
match everybody come on Chad that was
that's just a fantastic game that's why
you watch chests that was just awesome
brilliant and also encouraging if you're
if you are a dude a fan because you just
sort of punched back a little bit right
you're like look I'm not gonna let hit
caught a storm storm and make a comeback
just yet you know wow I mean he just won
the game of the match right like if he
loses that's our that's our moment of
the match no matter what happens I mean
honestly that was that was the moment of
the match right there okay but you know
we were excited right we're just here
comes a car speaking of creating his own
little moment of the man look at that g5
movie wants more he wants it I was going
I was going to say you know you can just
get caught up in the fact you just won a
nice game yeah you need to really buckle
down here and follow that up with more
victories or these more solid chests
because you know you don't want to spoil
that moment night 64 free pause I was
actually about to highlight how 92
attack the pawn and there it is free
pawn for Duda that's I just love the
comment from platinum member bobstine Lo
and Chesapeake at ease like it's amazing
that it Carly remains emotionless after
that game good shout out to roughly
11,000 of you watching this in English
across our multiple platforms we see you
no matter where you are we love you on
YouTube twitch mixer Twitter we see you
we love you thanks for being here thanks
for being positive and chest TV chat
thanks for being rockin today doo de doo
da de zippity-doo-dah a he's about to
win his second game bro that's a couple
of pawns and then beat bishop before d65
might fall next I mean my turn from a
couple into two couples yeah that's a
game the Karma's got to recover from
that for that crazy Wow hey we got a
neat house art in the chat
like Miele Soren yeah I hope Nihal
enjoyed that really beautiful checkmate
yo okay my car is the heart of this game
right there's chief he has he's gone
full Kings Indian hick horror mode right
he's gonna he's gonna completely lose
the queenside he's already dropped two
pesky but if he gets g4 and this becomes
a time scramble with a mating net don't
count her car out cuz h4 prepares g4 and
everybody is joining the party just f3
right now that he's gonna age for just
yeah I'll try to take away all the
squares say g4 l to take up my pawn
you're gonna go full Sactown here yeah I
know that you like to live in Sactown
but you don't ask me you know I'm paying
because it it's overpriced rent it's
like living in New York nice one but
look what's going on here Dubai that's
down Bishop takes chief for everyone's
favorite spot he's got his eye on it
right here
well come on every 93 rubgy three the
other one comes in g8 dude I'm not
kidding I don't think that dude is he me
so happy about this transition no this
is this is getting away from he's up a
piece in addition to the topology
already kind of stole over here but he's
got to focus
he's like all right he's like come on
he's giving himself a peck job I gotta
be able to figure this out leaning in
ink he can go rook f1 right and try to
yeah that's a good plan
rook up one work up to you the problem
is even if you get there I have Knight
h3 wasn't going to go rook F to us and
tried to take on that force in a remove
you're like very aggressive piece from
the action but this was a great move
because if black goes for this yeah you
got the Queen but you were already down
a piece so look at the material black
has for the lady that's a rook in to
bishops a lot yeah she lacks access
right everybody's guarded here what
about Queen b6 okay played in a g4 can
you bring that next night into the
action look at you dirty dog
this has a strange Indian you know some
sort of miguel night or of Zurich
International 1953 checkmate written all
over at hashtag look it up
hashtag make sure you read the book by
David Bronstein Zurich International
1953 it's a long hashtag but it's worth
it hashtag wait wait was this this is
not good
we need three here comes Knight g4 let
you four and you can see shoe first root
get you first
rook h2 King takes Knight g4 for town
and this time the main attack doesn't
stop wow this is dude no a car really
did just like he just like shut down the
queenside
it said like you're no longer in my
universe he shunned it and then he just
opened the kingside for the attack this
is just I mean real case you check you
win the Queen but you do have many
pieces for white that right because okay
he goes Knight g4 first that's what I
wanted because that something I wanted
to sack the Queen and find a mate I
don't see it but I wanted what Hikaru
did so queenie takes b6 you have to play
otherwise you're tweeting swedish new
king g19 h3 king of one he sees it okay
rook h2 King G one night h3 king f1 no
he's just taking a draw yeah is they
gonna draw and you can't go King up for
his match to his mate that's really
nasty actually yeah if white played King
a f1 night HT was made but the problem
is black can't get both and hold the
square so it's just gonna be a draw
yep Wow well isn't that just lame Wow I
mean rookie to check instead of 94 I
wonder what he missed or maybe what I
missed because I I'm not positive worse
I trust it carros tactical calculations
better than I trust mine to the Batcave
let's let's see that final finish there
cuz yeah it was a draw but come on okay
so he Caro and and Rob and I were
looking at rook h2 first now the king is
trapped you have to take there's a fork
on g4 you have to go to h1 because
otherwise I take the Queen with check
and I take maybe it was Bishop takes e5
check and then I guess you just like
take e free Robert and honestly yeah
that looks that just looks like White's
getting too much material so I'm kind of
agreeing with a Carter no wait but after
Knight g4 check and King h1 go Knight f2
check don't take the Queen what oh my
god on hold on rook h2 King takes Knight
g4 King Knight have to check and if King
H two rooks you choose mate
and if he takes it now you're meeting
him Bishop takes five King h7 I think he
did miss it
that's great gosh and thank you for
missing key snipers and all the love
that you guys have been giving us today
we're getting a lot of support from chat
subscriptions donations all the love
thank you we appreciate it
we're having a blast today I mean I have
trouble breathing right now because of
that last game where there's two games
ago I should say like Queen a3 except
for this one have a question for you yo
besides of course the matches we've
already discussed with Magnus Carlsen
defeating Hikaru Nakamura has anyone
been disclose with Hikaru I guess so
Wesley so remember Wesley so had a
two-game lead in last year's final and
last year's feat chess championship yeah
that was it the reason I asked the
question about the three-game lead which
we never got to because Hikaru came back
and swindled that game remember right it
was the last game of 5-1
I just went like little brother Don you
might member remember big brother we
were playing in the park and you didn't
pick me on the team member anyway but do
you remember that right so do two never
got to a three game lead so technically
the stat guys have to check on this but
I've done a lot of shows and I'm pretty
sure I've never seen hit karo trail by
three games against anybody who wasn't
Magnus Carlsen I think you're right
sounds right
alright well hey Carter now a little bit
better here as white we've got a deep
pond and an e pawn both are isolated but
I think that we prefer the knight in
this situation the bishop was kind of
awkward we do we also prefer the fact
that the black king side can become
quite vulnerable in near future with you
know rookie three ideas yeah so why not
94 here okay five dudes gonna take the
ladies home get get them out of here
yeah although the problem is if you do
that it Carl quickly trades and doubles
on the D file and you're forever
strapped with the pawn
that's a fair point right maybe you
can't do it okay
rook see here comes the Brooks to the
default anyway but the thing is the D
pond is not really hanging because it's
protected because the C pawn is hanging
so boy can you play I just don't really
know what move you can throw in here for
black so he ended up gone Queen g5 so
it's gonna transpose into the MOOC we
g5v played earlier and he's trying to
claim that okay my pressure on the C
file is enough to kind of offset this
problematic D pawn and yeah it looks
like a good end game for wiping this
isn't a Cara's chance yep so can you
play d5 here it looks very weird that's
that's one key question it's like a
Sicilian if you can do it and get away
with it you're solving all your problems
with black but can you get away with it
because if ya I think II five I think
your car was gonna sit tight keep the
dominant night yeah he likes it like he
likes it you know what he has Robert is
B for Brooke a three can black played b4
to stop your idea would be for huh maybe
in fact if you're gonna do it maybe now
it's the time because you also have
access to the c3 square in fact that
doesn't look it look at you but you can
also play rook c5 rook a fight exactly
is doing yes it that's a nice idea well
you set it up you set B for work a3 for
white so I said well what I say Phi for
black as usual the double D's here
overrated Dani the Brooks got nothing
you know normally I don't respond to
your your humor but are doubled on the
default they were overrated you never do
[Laughter]
let's talk about chess we're talking
about Robert I have no idea what you're
saying
alright rookie three you know what he
wants he wants east six cut off the
bishops protection of g4 but e six he'll
just end up taking it and then I'll play
d4 at some point I think and just see
two pawns hang what am I talking about
so he couldn't get away oh my gosh you
can't accomplish on cuz a beef
was a huge move by a car oh look at do
to shake in his head the point everybody
if takes fork town know that that's the
kind of move that saves a positionally
worse hanging because normally you can't
get away without the on passant problem
but he does it just like that with a
four that was a big move and he's gonna
look at it he's up the exchange dude hey
car was gonna go on to win and retie
this match I'm not so positive he's
gonna win this game just yet it
definitely is a good position for him
but if he starts gobbling up some of
these pawns here so he'd say he's one of
them is gone now rook c5 is in favor
cage check an f7 Falls you can't afford
got to the Brooks can quickly switch to
an attack mode right so there's not even
just about the pawns this King is kind
of in a weird mating net with the H pawn
already being on h4 okay so now though
now g3 and d3 yeah that looks at least
somewhat promising yet do it g3 would
check d3 okay if King g2 was gonna be d3
and then take but this is this would be
five is falling with check in that way
yeah acting kind of protects King okay
King B twos nice because now the rook is
sort of overloaded you can't leave the
bishops protection okay if you can guard
e5 then this guy will fall yeah but
things if I put my bishop on e6
I do wish my pawn on g3 was kind of back
on g4 yeah I was like five my bishop on
e6 everything's protected I feel like I
have sort of blockade going on so he
snaps off v5 and the issue is it's not
on the board here Robert yeah rook g3
Bishop e2 check King takes d4 he gets
away with it
Bishop takes a it's a draw but the
problem is the clock is this wrong I
think so I guess I thought with the okay
never mind that the ability to threaten
the sack into the King upon ending is
really key for white here in fact
admission now you can okay you could
almost do it right away but h5 and g5
first take it take it now in the key
figure now yeah he's calculating it you
just wouldn't a pawn he's getting here
Carlos sees it the moment he pauses
there if he was on camera he'd be
throwing us a hikaru number five yep
just double-check confirming does a
little bit of head nod take take take
take take I went that was her card
number five
but don't go g5 g six because then that
will she
that don't go anywhere everybody you're
about to learn some little knowledge
nugget put in your pocket okay if she
could still mess this up if g5 King h8
king of seven King h7 g6 is a draw
yep but you need to have be able to h6
but yeah you've got to put H by first
here I think
but h5 yes you can play or g5g v h5 h6
you take with the King and his winning
yeah
so he goes H we're gonna show you guys
this here in just a second because we
want you to feel like well yeah it's
going great today but at least I learned
something holding this this is a draw
what a save I told them not to do King
comes around it's over oh no the world
just happened there that went from
winning to draw to winning just like
that you said it the time the time was
the biggest play the next game is
underway but let's go back to the
Batcave here let me show it so this
final position just to clarify there is
easily winning cuz the king comes in and
this pawn Falls now we have two pawns
but this position here with that after
king e4 King e6 should be a draw king of
for the thing is you can't play king d6
right what should he play king of seven
exactly and if King II 5 king e7 if King
g4 then you come back to e6 so what
happened was instead he went instead of
king f7 wait no he ran the King away
from the pawn too far in a loud hood car
to trade it off so you have to the
reason why everybody if you play King of
7 and her car goes for the same idea h5
doesn't work ok no matter what because
the king is just the king is just
already in drawing territory in front of
the pawn so the net educational
takeaways with it so this is a
theoretical draw hit carl blundered away
as long as you keep the king close and
you always meet king ii Kingi 4 with
King e6 you have opposition and it's a
draw dude
blunders when he takes the King away
from the pawn and allows h5 to trade but
hit karu earlier we have to show so many
educational things here Robert I know
the other games going but it's crate
like this position if h5 and h6 I think
it just miscalculated this yeah me it's
a 60s King h8 right believe King f7 no
oh wait yeah you still they didn't know
then g6 no g6 you take the point
what an amazing I just learned something
about this so here's the point everyone
if you get King on the 6th pawn on the
5th here no matter what the timing is
gonna work out for you to win whenever
the King leads the way the zoogs wrong
will be there you can mark my words and
call me out later all right it works
King on the 6th pawn the Fed that's
winning so that's why I assumed this was
the winning plan but if you play King h8
if you take it it's it's a stalemate
draw no no oh yeah no no you have this
it was winning Robert King age 6 and
King age 7 I mean I'm behind you so I
don't really the winning idea if you get
age 6 king over you take g7 and on King
G you go to h6 not f6 cuz f6 would
stalemate but if you go to h6 the King
runs out and he and you're not
stalemated
yeah I'm following him the delay so I
don't it was karo he missed this h5 h6
plan but ultimately he goes on to win it
anyway the last time I wanted to mention
that Robert I kept saying is you never
want to push your Jeep on if you leave
with the Jeep on the king stalemated and
it's a draw no matter what you do
alright we'll go back to the live game
here but that's a lot of King pawn
ending stuff but it was winning for her
car before he bunted the draw I'm sure
of it now I think the H point I think he
miscalculated
he saw the snail main idea Robert for a
god he could play king h6 king h7
like I believe you man I'm with you I
just yeah I just don't have I fall on
you kind of but in looking at the game
live and I'm trying to multitask and
it's too much for me right now what
matters is we have a tight match and
that was an epic game and ultimately as
you said time pressure was really the
thing that it came down to for Duda
well this position looks good for Duda
right better for white you have better
place pieces you got controlled the D
file black has no activity whatsoever to
speak of and well he just goes ahead and
chops off on d6 I don't know if I've
done that yeah I would've started with
g4 kept the tension alive a little bit
longer he's played well but again at the
time is what I'm worried about here yeah
he's always down a minute on the clock
it seems you know and one of the
question is is why can a play for h4 g5
or h4 h5 or you know playing the
queenside at some point you might go
king c2 king b1 and cambree Steen a
Forbes the bishop cuts off feet I know
that's a fun idea though right if only
you could you could get there that's not
a bad idea Robert because if you make
that an access point you can play c4 c5
at the right time yes before is
definitely before now is also worth
consideration all be four takes you're
gonna play c4 no I'm just gonna take
back on before burning a king to b3 and
try to claim an advantage because I have
more space in the position you're so
smart you're so smart well right now
Bishop h6 played okay so now black is
throwing g5 that's a bishop that is
wondered too far so he moves it back and
ken black get away with f5 that's the
essential question here can black
actually break open the position first
he's gonna try and time is the issue for
Duda though yet again the white is
objectively okay maybe not anymore
because honestly if f5 happens I don't
think we can even say white is
objectively better anymore yeah let me
guess five is and so dude is gonna try
to prevent it with this move everybody
because he's gonna take and then say
well I'll use the chief
but he Karim I call his bluff anyway and
play a five I guess yeah Brooke
infiltrating the g7 is what stopped him
yeah you didn't like it
I didn't know if it was so good but okay
he goes he takes the same approach
eventually gets f5 Duda under time
pressure here got a speed-up but his
blue looks pretty solid as white you're
absolutely right though being given the
clock having 19 seconds left is not a
good sign here he's running on h6
eventually try to push Brooke on g7
claim space over there in the kingside
and cement this h7 pond has a potential
weakness the downside for white of
playing h6 some point is that you put
your pond a dark square so the rooster
traded the king can come back over the
Kings side trapping that pond yep and
it's a target for the bishop on that
color which is a good again long-term
kind of em game Wesson to keep your eyes
on you don't want to just put pawns
really nearly on the color of your
opponent's Bishop yeah
and yes I just used willy-nilly
appropriately Bishop to d6
yeah maybe King D six bring the king of
opposition okay I like that I think
black is doing very well here and this
the clock is really the determining
factor I'd say but the position is also
starting to really look good for black
cuz rookie ch3 is a threaten in your
future coming out for this H pawn now
that carl played this very well the
whole approach to it was patient
defended eventually broke with f5 and
now i think you can go for your plan
rook h3 why not you're also threatening
wreckage for in some positions in the e4
pawn zuv weakness i think this is the
best way to lose the pawn those who
trade the bishops in the process because
now black is up one pawn but it's this H
pawn you know flank pawns often they're
not the most helpful pawns and games and
okay he's trying to yeah lie I'm gonna
take and then try to ooh a four by akaru
that's a good move now b2 is also a
problem broke a Jack you up to tuck the
King back here comes aged five and
eventually that King is gonna try to
walk in ago C 5 C 4 b3 and he's gonna
get it although that king is coming
a3 pretty quickly as well okay it's over
h7 here yeah no dude
fighting him with only a few seconds you
got it this is a very well defended
endgame but I'm one even now dude it can
take on e4 and then go rook c4 works
ephod and should have wind his beep on I
guess King a3 is always coming at this
is like being one template so you could
get king c5 there rook c6 can be 5 owner
if he missed that he's trying to gain
time because it's the 1 second increment
but he's about so he needs to gain it
and that finds very nice move King a4
maybe four tries tell me yourself
oh so hilarious yeah this is losing was
the last chance you were right what a
crazy I owe he finds it rook c1 you owe
doesn't work though teen d3
oh thank you three super smart oh my god
that was super close you freaked out
there dude I thought he I thought he had
found a yeah there's no let's show it on
the analysis board the point everybody
we were freaking out we as in the Royal
we
including everyone even though it's just
me if the King moves anywhere else you
start with checks and it's still mate
renegade rook time but the things you
could even went back to d3 then it was
so before earlier was better right yeah
your your idea your idea here was better
play B for now because now the rook has
to run away because you're legit
threatening a stalemate it won't be able
to be stopped
so the rook has to run away and the
question is can you hold it now
something like this rook guards maybe
you bring the King back probably not
you're probably still lost but still was
worth a shot alright alright well car's
gonna say we haven't we haven't said
this yet in the match but we have a
happy Hikaru are you bringing out happy
a car Kathy a car oh he's leading in the
match for the first time all day and see
here I thought we were only gonna get
one expression from him for the rest of
the show most most of the day has been
this we are now in this
you know I the thing is I can't react
immediately because I can't see you know
for a little bit so when I'm not
laughing with you Danny it's laughing at
me you see no it's good I don't
appreciate you so absolutely still in
school Danny we're not laughing with you
were laughing at you guys flashback all
right
I'm not laughing about this position
because we're in my territory here when
an end game with you know not a
symmetric constructs here black has four
on three from the e2h file White has a
three on two from the a through C file
so in extra pawn on each side for each
player here and the bishops right now
look very nice for for black but this
bishop on d5 say that my bishops are
strongly centralized and an essential
question when you analyze a position
like this from both sizes what kind of
traits do you actually want does black
want to trade bit shows when Bishop g2
is coming which well it's happening
whether you like it or not and if you do
trade these bishops do you take on g2 or
play rook H to d8 and allow Y could take
you on d5 so you take with the epoch but
so he answers the question of what he
preferred watch out for Rick takes e5 so
I played with da yeah they block it
I can't thinking about the stalemate
Rick I think I think it did work because
in that line I show with rotation see
rook e1 you can take on e3 would check
Rakesh and the chess TV chat just
pointed that out and it's still me there
are so many ideas galore yeah that was
that was fun and instructive okay
Hikaru is gonna try to use the
three-on-two will it be faster than the
four on three find out next time no
kidding
in these games the three on two should
be the better majority than the four on
three right Robert well right now
because the Paul is trying to move in
the center I am actually quite happy
with them so he can just take on e3 c2
is it they just agreed to it you're all
they're like I'm not any good and I got
that and then not gonna try to win this
one anymore which i think was fair I
mean
they they're both fighting a lot dude it
is down a point now for the first time
in the match so he's willing to take a
draw and get the white pieces and he's
gone away from these efore you know
ephod Berlin's that we had earlier in
the five minute portion and now young
Krista was going for d4 lines so I asked
him yeah he went away from you for I was
just gonna say I wonder if that's his
own psychological kind of issues now for
the first time he was up two games in
this match if somehow you're just
joining us where have you been
so Duda was up two games he's now
trailing for the first time and so it
doesn't make sense for him to go away
from me for I mean he has been
successful with white all day with e4
yeah we should ask him for sure after
the match when we do interviews with the
players but we look at this position
here and well white is better here
anyway you have this if fewer pawns in
the queenside for white but this pawn on
b7 is sort of a permanent target not
really a weakness is hard it pilot
pressure on the bishops on that five it
takes away the move rook to be one
that's very important but you could play
rook a to Ruby two at any moment and
where's this knight on b8 going if you
go to d7 you simply okay this is clearly
good yeah something went wrong when
you're playing Bishop c8 I bet in three
or f4 no F 4 F six do you remember that
game Dani where her car was white
against cardiac in the Sinquefield Cup
yeah I can have like no development
whatsoever but yeah held on for a draw
well we thought we were convinced Takara
was gonna win right we feel like the car
was taking one from surveys book here
yeah like undeveloped as pieces of
saying try to beat me here to take on d5
right it seems clear to me take that
pawn open up more lines for your pieces
whether you take back with a pawn for
black then my Brooke comes to c1 I'm
just first the action with the white
pieces and he placed c5 because he's
just trying to leave b7 as a permanent
weakness but how do you actually push
forward he's gonna play f3 e4 that's one
idea
watch out for Bishop h3 ideas
potentially for black now just a final
finish the development he says I'm not
gonna allow Bishop h3 ooh now that you
got to consider the exchange Sakura
okay he doesn't look I guess it's
pathetic
you couldn't take twice with the rook
because then rook da would have been
good and the annoying thing here for
white isn't you can't over be one the
bishop covers it and the a5 point is
impossible to attack another the I am
now it can look very pretty you but you
can't get rook b6 rook a one rook a to
rook b2 right in that's kind of what
he's going for here dude is going for
the the slow-jam approach here on the B
file
yeah the rook a3 b3 but it's working
through this Bishop c4 so Sunday you
should be six first Ruby six is also
kind of irritating because it opens up
some weird tricks on d5 if you're not
careful that's very true
no you plays rook k3 but I still think
rook b6 should be played I also want to
play h3 just to make sure I don't get
background check mate it's a good call
the pro tip don't get back rank made it
in fact Queen B okay Kentucky one right
after the trade I was like hold the
phone okay
f5 then not sure I love that yeah that's
neither I want play on the King side
while you go tried to Mossman the Queen
side so I'm going to start pushing my
palm he's gonna play a four probably
lobs take it snap that right off I might
play a three then no if I take on that
four you're gonna play f3y Thank You tq7
I'm sorry nah man I'm snapping that have
forbidden meet me I know what you got on
the brain nothing apparently you're
silent based out there hello darkness my
old friend fo he he went for it hello
all right rookie was threatened so you
have to play either Brooke b1 or g3
actually create Street - yeah he fine
okay
I think that was he he wants the Queen
to go to g3 to offer Queen trade none of
these up a pawn yeah good point
look at your car though it's kicking her
hitting f4 watch this rook slide to a
one duel frets on the a pawn and rook e1
I'm like in Queens g3 here because I
don't want to play g3 and open up my
King even more so you played it now and
that way b7 is falling you can't protect
it and must be seven falls g7 is also
weak and so blacks attack looks a bit
slower than is necessary to kind of even
this one up yo yeah I agree
the Queen takes d4 rook takes b7 yep
and your rook a one idea just feels a
little bit too slow
yeah Hikaru under a minute car was under
on time for the first time in a really
long time yeah I mean I don't think he's
been the first under time pressure since
the game he lost my disconnection and
maybe that's why due to play d4 perhaps
just feels more comfortable in it in
this blitz games and he's actually up on
the clock which has been really the tail
in these yeah three minute portion he's
been in time trouble pretty much every
game and there's some times he could've
held that King a pawn in game yeah and
he just didn't have enough time to
calculate okay hey Carla's gonna go for
Queen d4 maybe that's the right choice
for a guard list because despite the
rook looking good on the seventh rank
you do now have the D pawn and sixty-six
of Threatened is a huge threat if the
Queen moves Mayton baked on g7 yep wait
it's a wing g60 you need to make space
for your king queen g6 King up queen c3
okay we're gonna find out rook check
King g3 Queen c3 f3 Queen e1 the King
runs to g4 and you're all out of goods
yeah you can also keen h4 instead of f3
just take it just take it you're fine
don't freak out just take it I already
freak out it's too late what do you mean
he's winning
kingi four okay
whoa don't go can't fire because new
bonejack we need a five would have lost
the Queen D three you lose the Queen Wow
okay Hikaru went a car went all in there
to try to try to to swindle that one but
due to ultimately gets the victory we
are tied again you know where else
Sakura went recently he flew to film a
show with HBO and apparently he will be
making a cameo in an HBO major series
now what we don't know if it's fiction
nonfiction I have a couple theories
about it but I don't want to say mine
because we have a lot of tweets to read
about this at the chess at chess aka
says Hikaru is going to appear on real
sports after all there's already an
episode about chess okay I think that's
a fair guess I actually have it on
authority it's not real sports so I can
say that I have a couple shows I can
eliminate that it's not Robert you read
this one I'm on delay so okay I think
he's gonna have a cameo on House of the
Dragon where the shows where he shows
the power of blacks fiend ket owing the
bishop and going for the opponent's
throat as fast as lethal as a knight I
feel like you're speaking Game of
Thrones and I blacked out an hour ago
let's move on okay
crazy coffee man says it's at show times
ray Donovan know it is HBO at giing him
Garo hires writer rile up Duda before
the SEC match there you go we get credit
for that maybe Robert Hess wants to tell
a quick story about a time he was
invited to appear on a Showtime show I
was invited so just brings up tough
memories but like me a lot of birthday
parties go ahead so Marissa Ashley was
on an episode of billions yeah a couple
years ago at the rock Johnson what
Dwayne the rock Johnson is on billions
he wasn't Paul Giamatti man oh yeah
that's the other show I think of all ur
smaller's yeah that is a pop culture
demerit for you right there billions is
a horrible show okay firstly you just
gotta stop for a second because this is
my
story to tell and you're ruining it all
go for it so so anyway Maurice was on an
episode a little while back and then I
got an email just a cold you'll be like
hey they would think about doing a
chassis and would you be interested in
doing a cameo and they ended up changing
the scene so I'm not doing any more and
that's the end of my story
hmm so you got written out I mean hey
it's in order to be written out so that
you can be on these shows was but anyway
jokes aside everybody our daily question
let's remind everybody real quick of
what it is because I think we are gonna
give away a diamond membership here
today if we get a great one the daily
question is which show do you think
hikaru is going to appear on it's a real
thing hey Karl went and filmed an
episode it's already over he will be
making a cameo on a show and and what do
you think it will be get involved use
the hashtag speed chess on Twitter you
can let us know and chat and we'll keep
track of it thank you yep and in this
game here we're gonna focus on the chess
yes yourself is that rhetorical my
sister parent you right now yeah yeah
okay
f5 trying to undermine the night here
but Duda says I don't care yeah because
the key isn't the wrong square the King
on f2 walks right into a check so now
you're gonna take on c3 open up the B
file for your rook now you can play rip
beasts you have an e6 is a problem so
play rook F e8 and just protect it
nice e5 then your c3 point hangs c4 e I
for a die no I'm kidding rook e8 I'll
play rook a six in fact I make over
ringing whoa he's just gonna give e6 for
the idea of a3 and rook b2 that's a
really nice idea yeah
so the Cardo does go rook a six so I
think he should play a three anyway okay
we're not never okay for Brooke 64 but
eat five falls why would we help a pawn
but they're split pawns on the Queen
side not easy to push yeah in fact not
easy to push it all night d6 is a good
move from Hikaru though especially when
you
up on the clock like this you don't need
to go for the forcing variations you
just kind of continue to confuse the
situation play a little tickle due to
just lost a few more seconds on the
clock now he takes it this is exactly
what Judah doesn't want because we just
applauded him for being ahead in the
clock in the last game which he in even
the score with now he's down over a
minute and the clock it's piece spinner
what ten seconds on rook takes e5 when
yeah that is planned the whole time why
I don't know I think he needs better
clock management these moments here and
what's really annoying though for white
is this many forces pinned so you're
kind of stuck mutually for the time
being yep and in PlayBook c8 here go out
for the seat bond brooksy85
awesome the way the rookin t5 is awesome
like rook c8 c4 played Knight b6 just
keep going out for the C pawn you're
gonna hard time protecting it King h8 in
what world is that move necessary he was
trying to avoid some weird discovered
checks or something yeah that was that
seems it also seems like a weird move to
play when you don't have any time on the
clock oh this is what he wanted because
he didn't want you to take with check
but is trading off you're actually good
like I don't know maybe he thinks that
it's harder for white to deal with the
pin than we realized
yeah he's a key gonna rip checking back
yeah that is your selection that's why
you played King h8 it's actually really
creative
the main point everybody is the pin on
the knight means that even he'd over way
to bring pressure if this rook starts
attacking other things all of whites
pieces are stuck guarding the knight and
so do two whoa he acara walks right into
the face of danger he's allowing ninety
five check well what is he doing
actually is this this is okay for him I
mean it's gotta be King d3 that came
running to see too I guess but rook at
three check and they need to recheck the
follow but one checks here yeah no and
you have to be really careful if you're
a Karl I think that honestly from a
practical perspective I like it
decision because due to only has 16
seconds but a rook beat you check here
rook beat you up like King c1 I guess
Wow
you just hang in one but you wouldn't be
- and all the sudden that King is
perfect I like will get through a lot
because c3 is now a target rook be to
check is still in the air Ranko king c2
cuz my III check i think having more
rooks on the board is good for blacks
chances 100% the king is kind of
vulnerable right yeah bring the road
back to have faith then bring in a c8
maybe rook BQ now king c1 no no this is
exactly a four yeah that was a big
mistake by Judah and he didn't have
enough time to keep finding accurate
moves I think and he kind of knows it
with that so it'll look right there like
that didn't go as planned
yeah he's getting you know just the
pawns are rolling now c4 c5 is going to
come a 5 a 6 a 7 8 is probably what's
gonna happen first Knight b5 well
coordinated here comes the a pawn baby
girl on a8 she's new to this world but
she's a queen
and because of that due to resign so
with only 6 minutes and 50 seconds on
the total in the total time remaining
really the biggest issue for Duda has
been on the clock right overall
consistently no time pressure I mean
Robert that game was totally holdable
black was fine but you can't keep
defending the most critical moments
living on the increment no absolutely
not and he's shown that he is incapable
acara has proven he's too strong when it
comes to the dwindling seconds there and
of course we're gonna mention that pawn
in game that was waiting for a car then
should have been a draw but you know
Christopher didn't have enough time and
that's where it becomes critical when
you have a 18 seconds left your opponent
has a minute left and you're trying to
find the best ideas as quickly as
possible but you're putting is sitting
back wait a second that last move
doesn't look so good let me take
advantage of it and this is coming from
somebody who's been a lot of time
trouble in his life again I'm really
glad you brought it up yeah I know you
don't like to bring up my flaws I bring
them myself and you'll just agree
I see you doomed who says it Caro is
gonna be appearing in CSI New York
unstable internet connection or bad
internet connection I love it
get that guy a diamond membership send
me a tweet I see you that's pretty funny
I see you do him send me a tweet you'll
get yourself a diamond membership
because I'm like that shadow to almost
twelve thousand of you watching this in
English and then we have lots of other
people watching in other languages I
don't speak any of them so I'm not gonna
talk about them just kidding that would
be a really ugly thing to say but you
can watch in French Russian polish
Spanish today in Portuguese yes position
here looks good young Christian good
position the clock 97 you should have a
good position in the last game 297 check
why is even thinking like the whole
point of this bishops tearing each other
down on the diagonal okay he played d5 I
was going right 497 check but what's 97
check just good game the two bishops to
the Batcave like this feels the opposite
of good
now you just down upon 97 check you take
I win the two bishops and I'm very happy
I agree with you a hundred percent well
you know what's not okay Queen d6 is
weird because you're inviting rook 81
with a tempo to me this the last this
whole game isn't strange frankly yeah I
don't really get what's going on because
the Queen's trying to keep an eye on the
East 7 sports mayekar is thinking
different position just isn't that great
friend even though he's up a pawn the
pond c6 the real thorn in the sides past
pawn in the making if I can get to see
some pot off the board so they're gonna
repeat this one you know and settle
because he's not happy with how he
approached that his white like you said
he had the advantage probably if he
plays 97 and the bishop here but he'll
get one more crack at the three-minute
time control assuming this game ends
quickly if not I mean it's possible this
could be our last 3-minute game and we
might be headed to bullet before you
know it folks so don't go anywhere I
think the car would be wise to agree to
draw here I agree you know playing Queen
age 5 in looks like I may have some
attack in the future but yeah dude is
not under time pressure or do does not
lower on the clock so if I was a car I
would also say you know what we'll throw
down and one more 3-minute battle where
I get the white pieces so I expect a car
to repeat
yeah and he--exactly you guess the white
piece in the final game yeah here we go
the bullet the draw is agreed so this
will pretty much officially probably be
our last three minute game so don't go
into everyone not only if we had a blast
today but we have a very close match
it is a one-point lead currently for the
favorite and bullets should be fun we
have some more responses people getting
active very quickly because of our daily
question at vy t farms in Silicon Valley
they had some chess scenes but
unfortunately Silicon Valley has already
filmed their final season
I actually know that cuz I was in it
keep watching okay just give me
explosion Jacob Fitzgerald says West
world would make sense perhaps as a
chest I had the thought it was West
world or Watchmen maybe it is ballers
anyway
okay next one watchman is is the kind of
naka show it depends on what the
character is right is it like hey you
know that's uh that's like one of the
that's what were they how would they
introduce them that's a car naka
moreover they're playing chess I don't
watch West world so I don't know you
know what he would be in that but it's
cameo so they'll have a chess scene
it'll be fun what is night f2d seven
what am i watching here Danny I know I'm
the one who typically plays offbeat
openings and things like this and I'm I
guess just going off the d4 pawn but can
i play Bishop takes f7 and Knight g5 and
respond to Bishop takes f7 King takes
ninety five and if you move I know my
puzzle rush I know how to pop a pony
nobody knows if Knight takes d4 he for a
check so what then I go king of so what
I'm telling you so what don't you so
what
alright well King f8 I don't care
Queen D Jersey or D - you're saying so
what I'm saying do - what you're talking
about different player all together
you don't know young Kristoff it was my
first time I've dude
you know what's going on you got so
quiet
I hope it Carla wins this game just to
prove you wrong
Wow you notice of root for the player is
Danny play c5 here protect that night
was an IG 7 going there's a trap pony
hey Carla's gonna have an attack and
he's got the dark square Bishop you
think I did that just for kicks and
giggles you speak weaknesses I speak
extra pawn in a fun looking position how
much you want to bet it correlates due
to the dark furs in this game what's it
worth to you firstly you're not allowed
to bet right now I'm not you're right
it's frowned upon it is I just saw you
don't when your Cardinals players got
suspended players apparently there's a
lot of that going on betting on your own
games on your own events learned your
lesson sir don't call them my Cardinals
when they play like this I'm ready to
scrap the whole Kyla Marie experiment
all right whoa whoa I just want to get
your attention
you weren't kidding you're frustrated
it's time to learn how to win a game hey
I'm liking blacks position here yeah you
would
hey Carlos still gonna meet you on the
dark squares actually thanks I'm moving
the Knights move yeah f4 was no good by
a guru
he's not gonna meet me I'm not playing
okay you're right I'm sorry all right
although no oh you know I was like why
do you play Queen takes f4 it's cuz
Queens on c2 all right it's ready I'm
not going back the dark squares
dark squares dark squares you got a lot
of them I'm a jay-z all up in them my
man I'm getting so distracted because
the chats like taught my Kyler is the
only QB who looked good against the
Niners I mean Kenyan Drake look good
against the Niners that game Kenyan okay
Queen d4 check you run I play g3
undermine the night at some point the
age file comes open don't worry I'll buy
you a beer after that's how it's gonna
happen
lady 3 first I love it yeah this is
starting to look really bad from well
plus the time on the clock I mean I know
we're having fun arguing but from a
practical point of view this has not
been easy for black from the start okay
right the lack of development the fact
that you went for this Bishop takes f7
you're right I was overreacted Bishop
takes f7 was not winning but still still
looks good for white although watching
for nice c4 coming back up
so Queen d7 looks like a must but then
just take on a4 and whites sitting with
a great position yet or even take oh yes
okay takes it for now that I'd has to
retreat oh gee - this feels like a pony
that's one or two for ya Hikaru was
ready for it too
the time is ticking he's gonna run the
King away what if King b1 is that rook
takes at five that would wait that's why
he played Queen back I think you got
worried about some kind of minute and as
you pointed out he's uh he's like I
don't need to meet you in the dark rooms
anymore cuz your knight is no good but
the knight does protect g6 and you're
running knight of three so now a car has
to be careful I think Brooke up - and it
takes you have rook to you one forcing
Knight g6 yeah rook if - does look like
a promising move right ah
wait.you finds another way he plays it
second time around again if you take
there's rook g1 that's kind of the idea
the king of seven can you just hide uh
okay okay
dude it is super versatile super
resourceful okay why can't I get at your
King and why don't you say make you burp
alright
honestly 993 comes you've gotten out of
this a hundred percent Wow
I'm shot cuz it looks so good for a car
rainy this is the moments where I was
applauding him earlier because he was
taking his time yep when he was up a lot
of time now he's moving very quickly
I think it's backfiring in this game
okay like blacks position here's the
problem even with all that work dude is
still down to seven seconds he's won
swindled by Hikaru away from blundering
he doesn't have any time to think about
it 93 okay 1 9 f3 tonight
oh gosh so hard to come up with moves
when you have 5 seconds left
yeah and now b6 is falling this is maybe
just a check no he's gotta guard it
actually wait that's actually really
hard to deal with though he's checking
instead wait King g6 did you actually
take the rook on e8 nicey-nicey to King
moves
whoa King moves away he seems ok you're
threatening rook d1 which is mate
everybody but it doesn't matter he just
gets rid of the bishop and it's over of
your piece and on the clock hey kar
Nakamura doing what he does best
and that's winning games in the speed
chess championship Wow again it's not to
say that Duda didn't defend that super
well but the time eventually caught up
with him yeah he can't be living on 5
seconds for too long because well the
guard was gonna make you pay now if you
had if you had to ask due to heading in
if he would take a two-game disadvantage
and bullet I'm gonna guess he wouldn't
have been thrilled because you know we
know how good a car was in Bullitt but
for some reason our smarter chess stats
have young christophe Duda as actually
the favorite in Bullitt we're gonna
explain exactly why that is when we come
back from a very quick break
don't go anywhere the speed chess
championship returns in just a few
moments bullet bullet bullet bullet can
do takedown akut and bullet he's gone I
have to play fast and find some good
moves let's see if Robert Hess has some
news it's bullet I can it says that you
literally just made that up right now
right now hey that was all you know the
only thing that was happening in the off
scene is me and my producer we're going
it's bullet bullet bullet anyway do you
got any news for us let's go to the
smarter chess predictions and talk about
how Danny was wrong apparently JKD is
not the favorite in bullet but it is the
time control where he's expected to lose
by the least lol
surprise surprise hey Karan Nakamura is
the favorite and surprise surprise that
Danny wrench was wrong well you know
what things good things do happen on
chess shows you know what else we've had
a lot of people with us today we still
have nearly 11,000 of you just in
English
let alone the other languages so no
matter where you're tuning in from
multiple streaming platforms thanks for
making us part of your day we appreciate
all the support we've had as well and it
does come down to this again if you're
just joining us
lots of crazy action today we've had
mouse slips miss clicks we've had
disconnection issues currently we have a
car Nakamura on a terrible internet
connection there but he will be back on
camera with us after interviews do not
worry
and we're ready the bullet is about to
begin
let's do this dude needs to get off to a
good start here we can win because I
cannot afford now go down three again I
know I sing a little song and normally
I'm wrong oh my gosh that rhymed but
Duda has been down two games before the
bullet portion he's been out more than
two right that's right
he was down three games entering the
bullet versus guru shuka in his first
year last year and he came back in one
he was down two games with six minutes
left so if anybody thinks that Duda
loses himself or doesn't have his wits
about him in bullet you'd be totally
wrong I'm I'm not surprised to see the
smartest chess smarter chess predictions
giving him a chance here yeah just clear
favorite for hey Karan right now in this
position I like what dude has done but
don't like his clock management every
game I think we've said the same thing
his position looks fine but then you
look at the clock I'm like oh that's not
good and just playing some offbeat stuff
that karo clearly feels comfortable with
and what's the idea here if you castles
in the twenty seven is left
undefended yes there's nice c6 I think
cuz that doubles the pawns maybe are you
see one perhaps I like that even better
gain a tempo here you can move the
knight with discovery obviously if the
trade happens you win e7 yeah he goes
for this right cuz you can't go Bishop
d6 exactly should be six now because if
takes in 97 we just completed each
other's sentence and I was a little late
my bad
Bishop d8 but now you can trade in win
ce7 yeah yeah it's obstacle Bishop
ending probably equal due to once more
yeah he wants to get activity he's
saying that I'm gonna try to be better
in this end game not just allow you to
liquidate but with rook e8 rooks gain
traded
and well obstacle and bishops even
amount of material hey car would be wise
to just keep playing this right yep get
time off that clock time off that clock
this is a the most drawn of drawn
positions well is that the most drawing
that's true King versus King is a little
more drawing there you go really stole
my thunder on that one
all right Bishop d2 to stop no actually
wait now his car was turning it around
rook c2 rug d2 I guess
look at he legit knows what he's doing
Hikaru is keeping the rooks on the board
on purpose if you're Duda just start
repeating now cuz your hope should be
that you just get a position three times
Oh h4 oh wow what a move okay G favor
sick pawn takes h4 one a piece everybody
I'll try to show it in the Batcave after
the bullet game is done a nice move by
Hikaru my car might just pick this one
up back yeah and again what we're
pointing out is regardless of whether he
wins this one every second off of that
clock there that's ticking 27 minutes
gets him closer to a victory so he you
know dude it is relying on the f6 pawn
being Bishop c3 here just kids you have
six pawn and I think he served oh no
don't take that pawn yeah no g2 is a
problem that was cured very strange
taking up six but now can you foreign
team okay so the East Cape on Picaro is
just he's so good in these positions
though I mean you can even bring the
king over and threaten ideas of sacking
at some point if the rooms get trained
it's immediately intro yes so that's the
good news for white the bad news is
you're down upon the boy he goes for
that idea I really that's this is the
right way to try for a win because if
you take and win this and then put the
bishop on g2 like you can yeah he's
trying to set it up he maybe he wants
the a3 pawn first he's trying to set up
the SAC so dude is trying to stop it now
Rick have to check H to check bishop see
silver give me AK win yep King King
moves h2 okay this is this works as well
but h2
is uh good enough and that's like I said
abandon all hope ye who enter here
bullet portion against a car Nakamura
never fun to be playing down against a
car in bullet Ches
well Duda started out started out well
again I think the time management was
something we've been critical of right
now look he's really put on the gas he's
got more time than Hikaru does currently
they're they're gaining on the clock
yep but you've got a strike now if
you're Duda it's victory time
yeah Knight takes c6 would have been fun
Duda wants that kind of stuff to happen
he wants a car to do something this is
unprompted
this is this is where he's like
especially with a lead he knows how to
play positions that like you can't lose
and you can take let's make a prediction
right now what's the total time on the
on the clock after this game is over so
it's about what 25 yes minutes right now
be like 1aq minutes 42 exactly yeah like
another three minutes coming off the
clock here super tough at least because
they're getting a second per move each
side but I'm sort of like blacks
position like it works in the D file
look better than the rook on a1 and the
rook on the H file and I like what dude
is doing he's playing for win yeah a net
that's probably your best try to view
right yep but it carves into play g4
there it is he undermines the pawns so
as soon as I complimented dude as
position all of a sudden looks like well
now you're really getting much out of it
here are you yeah but it's still at
least he split them now and the good
news is in some games the outside pawn
is good for black yeah the bad news is
well we're not getting into position
where that will come to matter right and
it's a Brooke ending the h-11 also can
become a target if you're not careful
rookie 7 is someone think about
hmm okay PA yep don't get mated but
exactly if you trade off these rooks now
yep then it would be a problem for white
but if the rooks come off now the
outside pasture will win for black
because you sack it you win the F phone
and your kings closer but look at a car
of playing the move a six can if I was a
very good response you got a guard c6
and hope your king can run in ooh
passive defense here but the TV for King
III all right keep the pumper that might
be it now he's spending b5 nice maneuver
by Hikaru serve rook b6 you gotta make
sure your rook is protected whoa he
doesn't do it okay rook 85 rook c5
that's really nice okay so he's still
fine but he I wonder if he missed that
almost like he found a nice way out I
mean it's funny we talked about that
maxime brush here the growl of magnus
carlsen endgame yep that yesterday or
two days ago yesterday it was like this
is still a draw but do not play like
this this might be one of the same
situations where yeah dude is still
holding and this is now easy draw
territory but it looks tricky for a
second there well they're they're gonna
they're gonna go back and forth here a
little bit of shuffle puck okay karu
Picaro is thinking about having mercy
gonna trade or just gonna let time go
he's let time go you're gonna let time
go yeah you're just well waste the next
30 seconds waiting there's 30 seconds if
you're dope he politely politely agrees
to the draw there so that was uh not
necessarily the best overall
gamesmanship strategy hakarl perhaps
feeling feeling pretty confident right
now but overall the the main thing is
that Duda has to get up on the clock
here now I know he tried that game but
he was black and a car took a very good
opening choice a lot of simplification
they were in a rook ending what a move
15 so you got to mix it up you gonna get
up on the clock and make it sharp three
game leaves for a hit karo here and so
um making this sharp right now we're in
one of these kind of sharp positions
where if you end up taking on d4 like 94
and 94 84
see three-second rest upon tragic blast
position open and hit car very wisely he
opts for the tame position the closed
position saying alright let's be chill
you're gonna prove that you can outplay
me in the structure we saw them play
this one before and dude have got a
pretty good position he not this exact
line but a close Spanish but ultimately
that was one of the crazy ones where her
car launched that wild attack on the
Kings side
Briony he ended up making a draw there
yep from a crazy he was first down two
pawns and much worse then he did a Kings
Indian style attack and then somehow the
game ended okay here this looks much
more promising for a car than that one
did I mean I know he launched an attack
but you know there's part Bluff like
yeah this looks good for white because
White's the only one who can start
pushing forward on the Kings side the
Queen side totally closed yeah that's
true yeah this might be a Kings Indian
attack for Judah if you could go on a
king journey right put on your running
shoes forest get out of here and look
he's gonna do it oh I love it
there you go just keep going just keep
swimming at four at some point is
obviously going to be a consideration
right and ooh g5 I don't know if that
was right for a car now you although I
guess he's saying I could just lock it
up yep here's Queen f3 though and she
gets to go back to G if he needs to stay
on the Kings side that's a problem night
at five nine H five hits hits f6
how does he break through some guy
soccer physis c5 at the right moment
something you want to double rooks on
the h-file move the Queen and get the
other Knight to f3 so you can really
break through on G fo whoa you must see
something we don't know he's in 96 nine
at four oh that was that was not the
right decision when you owned the
tension there you've got to build on
that everybody that was do don't do to
miss evaluated something there that was
that was definitely the wrong play okay
but actually now all of a sudden you
can't take on d3 because there's gonna
be ideas the g5 pawn right so you have
to be very careful from both sides you
goes 93 Knight of 5 is coming at the
right moment right here it is 93 he's
ready okay
hey tick with the G pawn on f5 okay so
just like you get there and I trade them
what
yeah that's great there's also a good
question he'll think that he had many
more cards if he if he built on the
tension there yeah now it looks like
even if you get those maneuvers in
nothing is wait he's gonna prepare to
sack on c5 or something wait now that h6
pawn can you so queen h2 guess you're
not really in time you can flip fish
opee to guard a three so the rook is
free Jochen yeah queen behind the two
rooks put that thing away you got a
license for that that's an L yo hands
gun I've been waiting to use that for so
long
you had your moment it happened
now you take a bike up and retire and
I've been waiting oh man this is the
worst situation yeah this is the worst
for duty you know we have to give a car
a credit be we're gonna be bringing back
more man versus machine matches you and
I we're doing commentary for those where
we would have top grandmasters throw
around against Komodo in the computers
right in like different material
imbalances we also did that twitch
rivals
event that a Carter played and where you
try to take on Komodo kind of the boss
rush right from zero to whatever but one
thing hit karo does so well in those
that you and I talk about that he's kind
of doing here is he's so good at
dictating the opening / the situation
like how many times does he get the
right opening against the computer where
again yes it's still a computer but how
many times does he get those positions
the only few positions left that we know
computers can miss evaluate in terms of
space in terms of pawn structure and a
nose isn't the same but look at what he
just did here he just took five minutes
off the clock wait he blundered now yes
yeah we did blunder
no he's oh he's gonna win now because
due to lost it do to win on tilt now
Queen d2 comes in and though that's
right
what a karo does is he's so good at
dictating the game based on the match
situation I mean I'll let you talk I'll
let you answer that once this one's over
but I know you and I have talked about
that a lot and it's it isn't the most
important X's and O's skill but when it
comes to the practical matches like this
it really shines through by the way he
is gonna win this game I don't know
Bishop C 292 that he's gonna work it in
did arm square just crazy
this reminds me helping Carl plays
against the computers no you're
absolutely right he'd makes a million
moves the other computer ends up doing
something a little nutty and he when he
sued ICC way back in the day yeah but
yeah backs up way past his bedtime
enough to message his dad like hey you
know just any old tell him to go to bed
now this is meat 92 Queenie one is made
now quit HD ones a free piece that came
too crazy heifer we feel the same way
dude it just how long did that game just
take like seven minutes
and Hikaru won only because Judah went
on tilt and played Bishop takes g5 let's
go back and just show that moment again
it's not to say that that the point is
due to got frustrated here he doesn't
have to play Bishop takes e5 but Hikaru
again just dictated this game created
this closed structure where you know he
was gonna continue to milk time off the
clock and due to said I can't do this
anymore I got to create something but in
the end it was sort of you know blinding
himself convincing that this was okay
but it's actually very quickly you
realize that was that was not right all
right back to the live game but
seriously and again it's you know we
know he does a lot of things well but
that's something that Hikaru does
uniquely maybe better than any other top
grandmasters on the planet because he's
played so much like you said on ICC when
we were younger you remember Hikaru like
I made jokes about staying up too late
but he would throw down against like the
crafty on ICC right and beat the
computer in blitz and bullet by playing
these openings that the computers would
miss evaluate space and and miss
evaluate things like the bishop air the
things where you could really recognize
the few weaknesses left in the algorithm
and it was just crazy crazy so wow look
at do to go here though he's winning
this one's taking the b-pawn and that's
gonna be a runner
there's no attack for white there is a
clear path palm for black and this
spells bad news for hikari Nakamura in
this particular game of course he's
still up for it's gonna be three after
this one but a good strike back for Duda
yep so what just rooks e2 here or
something just push that beep on he's
thinking spending the time there's rook
c2 now okay can't go be to you're hang
your rook and see - I was about to
blunder that so you need to move your
rook again I guess work e - coming up -
he five pawn this look looks good extra
pass pawn for Black Knight extra pawn
because you've even number material even
though we're pawns but yep look a little
push
so what's the threat now Ricca for I
guess it's trying to go to b4 and that's
mating on the back rank oh okay he's he
stopped the back rank mate but now his
rook is pinned to the Queen and how do
you get out of that wait this actually
is really irritated yeah I'm not sure
how you get it looks like his rooks are
stuck there ambulance arriving just in
time yeah for that rook it's like let me
extricate that piece here but Queen e5
we have three Queens shakes his head
that got away from them everything going
wrong for Duda he's now gonna be down
upon rather than promoting a passed pawn
this is just this is terrible it also
might just be losing as well how many
how many ambulances are gonna drive by
your window right nobody it's just one
and it's moving but you can hear a man's
from a while away are they coming to
rescue you I don't know if people from
small towns know these things but when
there are other cars around stuff like
that really twice if you're being held
against your will
yeah that joke is played out man I'm
gonna link twice because that joke was
so bad there you go
thank you thank you for that actually
sweet are you okay though seriously
okay shout-out to chess Brainiac one
three in the chess TV chat who says
wants to know if he'll get a token or
premium membership if he wins gets the
move if you win guess the move I will
give you a diamond membership how about
that okay
no just chess Brainiac chess Brainiac
goes and plays in and wins gets to move
if you finish in the top five after one
game I will give you a diamond
membership I've been watching guess the
move if you want to play against them by
the way you can go over to chest comms
live server and do so right now avi
Aachen art got art got tough
Ark Adi is 14 out of 37 on this game
good for him though
get in there chess Brainiac go get
yourself a diamond membership courtesy
of Danny has too much time to kill time
to kill and it's not really too much
time but it's working it he's working it
he's spent a lot of time in this game
yep and we're already in a territory
where it might be impossible for young
career stuff to come back
because of how long he's became a team
Oh again it we kind of set it up and we
were saying like you know what did do to
need heading into bully he needed a lead
and part of it was it was not just
because okay it's nice to have a lead
against a carro and bullet but also
because of Hikaru's gamesmanship that he
does better than everybody else I mean
he's literally how many this is gonna be
the fewest amount of bullet games we've
ever played right like I mean seriously
this is game four and bullet and we
might only get like seven games against
Game four and we've lost twenty minutes
on the clock I mean it's just it's just
crazy it's crazy you can do guess the
move at chess calm /live thank you
hundred Mike are moderate over there
sharing the link to Diamond member dubs
one two three shout out to everybody
that's with us I'm gonna address this
only once because honestly it's so
ridiculous that I don't really respond
to most the trolling and Chad but for
those of you followed the speeches
championship we've actually had several
matches in history where people have
lost their camera because of bad
connection and we've done this before so
there are zero special treatment going
on and in all of those cases the
opponent gave permission Judas said he
was a hundred percent okay with this and
if anybody thinks for a second that our
algorithm in terms of anti-cheating has
anything to do with people on camera
then you're missing something so it's so
ridiculous I even have to say that but I
just we're going to squelch it right now
so from here on out mods you have
opinion should just mute things if the
conversation continues so hey karo was
in a tough situation today with his
internet and he will be joining us but
we'll just address that real quick so
there you go Robert hey kar Nakamura
what are you gonna say well I was going
to say that dude it was you know he was
great about it he was sure that's fine
but he was also great earlier in the
blitz he had his chances to keep the
lead yeah he did and right now look at
this position with the double e pawns
for black the e5 pawn is actually under
attack and can be captured so young
Chris I was thinking about it because
the d5 pawn is now under threat as well
because the 9c3 is pinned this is uh-oh
it's a Queen's I was gonna say this is
an Enzo right up my alley for black I
checked on the east co there but black
I mean you see you're saying you like
white here right I'm not sure but I
don't like what's clock management okay
this is gonna say like this reminds me
of of an Enzo I had once how'd that go
for you
Siberia you do the math but no but no
these go these positions often kind of
worry it's it's weird cuz white gets a
huge Center and black looks like the
position is hanging on a thread but in
the end we're in an end game where you
know okay actually the position is
probably just totally balanced but I
think black is fine
he's not better but but fine well I
actually like black splishing this end
game yeah 95 is perfectly placed here
comes defund and soon comes C 5 if you
haven't get into z7c 5 right now and the
c4 pawn is under attack play d4 there it
is now I've a protected passed pawn and
oh nice capture c4 first he would he
said he flip-flopped the pin black spawn
was pinned on d5 now White's pawn is
pinned on d4 yep d5 you okay you can't
play rook f6 but maybe put a rook on d6
first - oh I thought you couldn't cuz h5
but he wants to trap the night okay he
trades the d Frey I don't know that was
the best decision for a car honestly I
think you could have slow jammed that a
little bit better but maybe the C pawn
is just strong and the bishop on d3
nevermind I'm wrong again
white yeah let's get let's get very
close yeah White's in trouble the two
pawns are too fast
here come the pawns and they're queening
and unfortunate for young Christoph this
is just well out of his hands at this
point yeah the car Nakamura is gonna
punch his ticket right now into the
semi-finals with only eight minutes left
a five game lead this is just super
tough and right now dude is hoping to
get on the board here and pull it with a
victory so tough stuff and you played a
French so that's why I am that's why
you're silent yeah a moment of silence
although all things consider this is a
pretty decent French because your
bishops not there
Castle queenside yeah we try to get
counterplay over there on the Kingston
yeah if the F file gets going you also
have h6 in chief 5 which is kind of a
common sack to create counterplay over
here oh that's a nice move though so
much for that yeah now looks just bad
yeah
it looks bad again hashtag the French
this pawn structure from b2 to e5 yeah
however we do that a lot
wait it looks bad again hashtag the
French it's as always happens right
never we see the French oh gosh not
liking this and here comes a meeting
attack probably so how do you actually
check me though I see the DA he's lost a
lot of pawns so he's down to pawns we
now see threes about to fall on that
nice gonna take on c3 go Knight d5 and
yep that b5 by g6 actually you can even
put the bishop on d6 if you're into that
I was thinking about that before him in
92 like did he six squares maybe good
oh he's gonna repeat no no repeats it
the second time
I think Bishop a three by the way might
have been better but alright hey Carter
still has rook up seven coming this
still looks super scary you can't take
an a3 he's maybe five checks Oh
fisherman's knot hey you saw the look on
my face
I actually didn't play felt it you know
damn that's a fork buddy do your tactics
kids don't end up like me
rook takes a three-night be five that
means blacks position is is running out
the thread is missing yeah it's another
defeat for mr. Jeon Kristoff here it's
going to be so frustrating to play hey
Karan I've come work for like 30 minutes
trade of blood you guys seeing bullet
yep in like three hours or so
listen bullet and just I'm winning you
don't have to games my next is one you
know obviously we know how tough a karo
is and we know that you know there's
probably gonna be some other critical
games due to which is he can head back
but I really feel like the overarching
storyline of why he went away from efore
that's something we have to touch on in
the interview you know be very
interesting to hear what his rationale
was because the positions he for looked
very good to us
but there must have something he didn't
like after all and here come the Kings
side pawns for white yep trying to
create a passed pawn get rid of the jeep
on throw the h1 down the board and wait
so sir
oh wait if the King escapes hey I may
have a new home on the light squares
look at that comes in b5 and Queen by 7
though here it is ok what is what
bishops ok that so does Bishop c7 know
Queenie sings me I'm so glad that you
pass all the tests I throw at you little
test here a little test there you know
I've learned over time - yep Queen a6
check Queen Kings before Queen 83 check
pick up the rook and there's note yep
Queen a3 Brook Falls and with it
officially the match likely does and
wowzers wowzers oh man well again I'm
trying to think of interview questions
you know I think that I think that the
e4 situation was definitely curious we
can ask young Christophe how he felt as
the match kind of got away from him a
little bit but in the end what we know
is what we know is that it's really hard
to compete with a car and bolt and
bullet but guess who at the moment of
the match today Yonkers
we're gonna get into that in a little
bit because that was as then if you
missed that you're gonna want to stick
around because in about yay oh wow we're
almost there and about yay four minutes
time we'll be headed to interviews and
we had maybe one of the greatest
speeches championship games of all time
Robert would probably already dub it the
greatest but I'd have to think about it
for a little bit I definitely have
recency bias but I can't remember a game
those back yeah it was literally an
absolute brilliancy by Jung Christophe
Duda and it was a blast commentating on
it to go with it so the unfortunately
then oh that gets you was like a pat on
the back in a moment of the match
sticker but you know we actually have a
moment of the match stickers we send it
to you and Yonkers has got a few of them
on his like shirt
yes it's funny you say that because I
was just thinking like what can you get
for a brilliant game some tournaments
over the board sense and brilliancy
prizes which is you know always a fun
little thing but yeah all he gets is
well you got the car angry and then a
carro said I'm gonna just eat you the
rest of the way and since then it's been
all hey Cara Nakamura yeah we saw a stat
earlier where it's been nine four since
the three one portion started and well
yeah we think the king is surviving the
keys run to a four okay okay wait nice
III know oh it's pinned oh actually
there is the what a nice to do King V
three back so actually well now there's
threats of like Knight b6 check and oh
wait the knight guards the Queen so
actually white is totally fine here well
you just need to figure out what you
know a good move
yeah what are you gonna do rook takes g7
this is interesting because he's kind of
offering a draw with this no he's not
offering a draw with King b3 he's trying
to run away I was just gonna say baby he
knows there's only two minutes left and
he's like what am i dear but we know
Duda wants to play for the win
damn he's playing for a loss I think I
mean if six comes d2 is an option like
white doesn't have an attack here okay
Queen e2 trying to meet um b2 is you got
to bring your work to h2 or take on g7
one of the two rook g7 q g7 Queen D oh I
thought Queen d4 Queen d4 would probably
been a draw I guess of the night of six
Queen takes rook there's Queen c2 Queen
C three checks forever yeah we already
know dude who doesn't want to draw he
could have had it if he wanted to keep
his king over there on a four very
likely we will have at least one game
after this but who knows maybe this game
lasts a whole nother minute and 20
seconds with this time trouble and Duda
really struggling with limited time the
clock I'm not sure this came one end in
the next few minutes seems like it will
yeah but we've seen we've seen crazier
things the increment
making a game lasts way longer than you
normally would okay now what so white is
up a pawn and somehow is the safer can
yeah somehow Quint is somehow due to got
out of that alive 22 Jackie of 27 check
oh but it doesn't win the night but you
have who's that Forrester okay he's
risking up dude I'm not afraid to move
his king up in this Queen g6 mate oh my
god I'm like looking at the positioning
wait wait where's the follow-up that was
a double attack night and made on g6
all right well Duda will not go silent
into the night when it comes to bullet
oh look at that we have the bong cloud
we had requests for it
a carro goes full full stream plays III
e2 now if you're Duda you want to beat
him here but let's be honest other super
grandmasters have also lost to a karo in
the bond cloud so it's not the worst
thing yeah you know he's having fun he's
already won the match so why not and
Swede a poor do you remember the Wesley
so mom and jar of match for they paid
like a 3h six or something like that
yeah yeah well where do we have that
recently we had Wesley so who was the
match he just played versus fel no no it
was against mommy juror though that was
before but just recently the match with
mvl they had some trolling there in the
end remember you're probably right you
know Wesley enjoys a little bit of
trolling every now and then well he
usually doesn't start it but he does
play along yeah he's a friendly guy I
think a car was gonna regret the bond
cloud on this one though
you mean the King on e one that can't
Castle right yeah is a problem and the
fact that night takes f3 check is coming
and yeah net phone Dingley rent also got
jiggy with it I don't remember what do
they do they play they had some bad some
fun just some silly openings yeah Harry
Met Sally and I think enjoying the flank
going to flank opening tonight takes up
four check Casey for is not hanging
because the work on d8 needs defense
so although now
cuz Bishop ephors are my queen tasty for
for white so that's gonna be a problem
for black mmm that's actually a really
cool trick it takes you take and you're
exposing the back crank actually gotta
be careful with that move Queen before
I'm just gonna say you're you gotta be
careful cuz you're overloading the Queen
now due to getting under time pressure
here Cara wants to survive a blonde
cloud he might just win this game even
the extra material is due to sax the
Queen okay cuz the car doesn't want it
yeah but watch out for Queen a - ooh I
think you might have missed that Oh
Queen c4 here only move because you
can't take Queen c4 if you take Queen g8
ooh maybe Hikaru missed that no he has
something better
well f6 is hanging so at the very least
at the queen bee - it takes Knight yeah
that was a mistake there by a coral
Queen c4 now he's just getting a check
on on it oh I thought he was gonna check
on f8 first and then take but same thing
okay seconds though due to living off
the increment will he sent hit karo home
with a bomb cloud loss 94 check is
possible but what does it do he's just
grabbing every pawn queen 8 you oh there
you go
c5 was like the move you just instantly
that'll do it Hikaru Nakamura goes down
swinging in a couple games but
entertains his fans in the process
ultimately he does move on to the speech
his championship semi finals in a game
that was full of dirt and a day that was
full of drama and fun we have interviews
with the players in just a few moments
so don't go in and when we come back we
are joined by both players this features
Championship returns
[Music]
you were talking and I wasn't okay I
look first I look anyway
okay everyone if you take the Queen it
was made and now he's guys we Nate you
full free players and you know I'd never
rude against a car not for more when
there's speeches no Queenie we have a
party
nineteen speeches championship the last
quarterfinal is in the books at car
Nakamura wins by a score of 15 1/2 11
and a half
thank you everyone who's with us here
for the interviews young Christoph I
know that the day didn't go your way but
take us back to that game where you
played Queen a3 and then you played
Queen a1 that was fun right we can't
hear young Krista
don't say that damn which one was you
don't remember the game Robert almost
fell out of his chair control I mean I
didn't expect to get to zero games and
and yeah and then I lost many games I
think by that I mean thanks Hank
I think the crucial game was the one
which in this modern I don't know how
it's called g6 yes okay I was in case of
+ free would be I think obviously that
still would be I would have to play a
bullet but okay I would be in very good
spot but instead I lost very easily and
it was kind of very annoying to me I
mean obviously we both missed very
simple tactics I think Hikaru you can
also have internet in truth so and he
also must with in the very first game
and was kind of very surprising to me
but okay such which happened and yeah I
know getting the bullet I did everything
well Hikaru back over you and young
Christopher obviously kind of touched on
it right there was there was a mouse
slip in Game one
you had internet issues and and you
you've played in more speed chess
championship matches that anybody right
so you have experience but today what
today was definitely some new obstacles
right you normally don't have internet
issues and you normally don't have Mouse
lips so how are you feeling at that
point when 3/1 started were you kind of
giving yourself a pep talk and trying to
keep the nerves calm or take us through
what was going through your head there
yeah um well I mean I think young
Christoph hit the hit the nail on the
head which was the Guren indie game the
the modern is it with the c6 he was
completely winning young and if he wins
this game I mean I think he was smashed
it's pretty much I felt like I was on
tilt for the whole
until probably the bullet section like
even in a three plus one like I was
moving so fast there's this cleaning a
3-game which like I think I just even up
the score and then it's like okay I'm
gonna castle right into this diagonal
cuz there's probably you know nothing of
course there's cleaning it through which
is a very nice move yeah so I mean I
thought it was on tilting I thought it'd
just be on Christophe he's a little bit
his time usage relative to the moves he
was playing wasn't quite right he got I
thought pretty good positions and in
most of the games but then like he he
didn't he didn't put it away like there
was also this um there was this also
this game with this Italian where I got
this crazy attack on the kingside and I
think he was just completely winning
that one as well so I I mean I was just
very much on tilt so I felt for the
whole match but I found a way to to win
the games that mattered in the 3+1 and
that of course Bowl it was pretty smooth
yeah and young Christoph have a question
for you and early in the match you're
playing efore and facing the Berlin line
several times and then you switch to D
for what was it that made you want to
switch your first move of the game I was
yes then I switched before I mean I
prepared my only son lines of 24 but
even they didn't manage to play them in
this match because okay I've got
battering I was getting quite good
positions I mean quite easy to play at
least and and yeah well bulletins didn't
really matter because yeah my reason I
think and because he's like was just my
time aside but in case I would be
winning in a match possibly I always
have quite quick when I was impressed
kora I started to to check everything
twice and yeah is Goro I you're normally
someone who puts other people on tilt
and the chat is the chat is kind of
loving loving what you're saying there
your honesty that you felt on tilt and
and let me ask I mean as someone who's
used to leading in these matches and
hasn't trailed many of them do you do
you feel like today made you better in
that sense because you're not normally
put in that spot to kind of deal with
some of these practical issues and do
you feel like maybe going through that
is actually gonna make you even better
in these matches to having been down
almost three games in the match but
ultimately make it a comeback do you
think this pays off for your own
experience I mean I finally so I would
think I was down two games there's this
critical game where I think he was all
there's also three in the 3+1 I think he
was beating me and I managed to turn
around and win that game and then it all
went my way so it's not the first time
this has happened but I think the way to
lose like on a disconnection is force
upsetting but to lose once like you've
gotten the winning position like you
played a great game
right turn like mash that should be even
at 2-2 it's obviously very upsetting but
having said that I also felt that when I
think beyond Chris off in a in st. Louis
on
final day like the last couple of games
he also found a way to put me on tilt so
definitely some credit to him because he
did play he did play quite well it just
there was like like that one critical
moment in that that game of three plus
one which really changed everything so
there was a good oh good Robert well I
have a question for you young Chris um I
guess couldn't remember this brilliant
Queen a three and then Queen a one
checked and the game and we talked about
your you know disconnection your mouse
slip but how did you recover from that
loss because that was a really you know
the Queen III was a really nice shot
it's unexpected
and then you just came back you know
good shape you maintain your composure
and were able to win the rest of the
match so how did you keep your cool
after such a nice win on Yonkers so
sparkly sure but no I mean I think the
thing is like I was not I was not I was
not I was not in a good mood I wasn't
keeping my composure I just moved I just
played bad shots and I moved very
quickly but Johann Christoph like his
time usage he didn't use time at the
right moment so he like he used the time
when the position was when the position
was like when I in the opening where I
was doing some things that were a little
bit dubious as opposed to like once I
had already gone gone off off the rails
in the like late middle games I thought
like I was not playing well I mean
composure is a very generous because I
definitely was not opposed I was just in
a bad mood though and I tilt the whole
uh the whole time was the mouse slip in
game one was it a Miss click it was a
big I clicked the pawn on d5 and then I
think I touched the knight like okay
it's okay I mean it's but you you got to
chat into a viral debate about whether
you're whether someone is a clicker or a
dragger right because you can drag
pieces or you can click so we had a
whole long debate about whether it's
best to click or drag your thoughts
click or drag I mean I clicked obviously
cuz it's just quicker but you know I
mean I think the thing is like in the
first game that's upsetting but that's
not you know it's not that big of a deal
but then that disconnection really just
like it put me on tilt like that that
was a
lot worse psychologically then the other
mouse it was the mouse oblate first game
the match like okay you lose Eoin the
mouse look big deal I mean it's got
three hours to recover but you know it's
yeah I mean you put you clicking and go
from there but yeah that's just I'm not
happy with the way I played today but it
seemed to be good enough but young
Christoph back to you for the first time
and you're speechless championship
career you won't be in the semi-finals
right and I know you've only played two
years but what did you what did you
learn from this match you touched on
earlier that once you got the lead maybe
you started trying to be too precise you
started using too much time because you
were up two games
what other takeaways do you have from
this match that you would apply that
let's say next year speeches
championship yeah that's might be a
reason actually because in a couple
blast days I try just like 30 seconds
per game or even 10 seconds per game
just so you know just practice but in
general I think I wasn't prepared enough
good enough still obviously I think them
that match was quite quite entertaining
and I to be honest I didn't really think
that because yeah yeah steer I mean it
was I think this game is very game is
modern and was the one which after a
which with which I lost I I thought that
okay it might not match well we really
appreciate it and your humble and we
know you have a bright future and
obviously you considered yourself the
underdog but it was definitely an
exciting match you guys entertain us we
had we had tons of viewers and it was it
was a lot of fun so I don't have any
other questions unless you do Robert I
have one last question
go ahead card you're up next for you is
Jana pom to see great quality what do
you think about that match how do you
stack up against jaan who of course is
next on speed chess player
yeah I mean I actually I thought I
thought I thought that Yong Kristoff
would be a tougher match that then Jung
nikomia achi not like not to not to make
dr. oz a very strong player but I played
Yahoo now a lot more he also he's he's
much more liable to tilt so I like my
chances again it's who knows when the
matches I but I'll I'll do some prep and
and hopefully things work out and I'm
sure regardless I'll be playing him in
Moscow so a very very familiar opponent
we've had many great battles but well
yeah and I think a lot of people
consider the favorite there too and we
are greatly looking forward to that
match I'm glad you touched on it because
well right everybody look out for dates
being announced we're working pretty
hard these guys are very busy as it Carl
just said he's heading heading to yet
another event so we will have
announcements very soon about when the
next speech has championship matches are
but tomorrow is our Tim universes so so
we already know that but dick Caro
congratulations young Kristoff thanks
thanks for everything guys this was this
was really was an exciting day and best
of luck in the next round Hikaru thank
you
all right and there we have it our
players they were awesome that was that
was good and actually it's nice you know
Hikaru opens up about being on tilt
there Robert he kind of knows that he
needed to get a hold of himself
regardless of connection issues and and
I think they're right I think that
critical game where we were both like
wow Yong Christophe is about to take a
three-game lead I even asked the
question has Hikaru ever trailed by
three games to someone not named Magnus
Carlsen and the answer was no and he
didn't trail then he managed to make a
comeback there if that was a huge game
and of course both players open and
honest with everybody saying alright the
mouse slip was unfortunate the first
game the disconnection of course kind of
helped young person do to get ahead in
the match and then young christen just
said you know after that game I lost
where I was winning and he car
checkmated me it went downhill from him
and I enjoyed hearing him talk about
that psychology when you're up in the
magic can be perfect sometime to keep
the lead whereas he should have trusted
himself and he said it wasn't my match
after all for Hikaru to admit that he
was tilted and also he gave great praise
to Duda he said he's a very worthy
challenger in fact Young said he was
probably the one of the players he
thought he'd have the most trouble with
that anyone in the field and that is a
great sign for both these players very
respectful of the other and they played
a great match no I mean that is high
praise and we know the car was very
honest in his interviews and and you
know he didn't win this he didn't win
this match by as big a score as we
predicted or not we the smarter chess
prediction so that is that statistical
compliments going to young Christopher
do too regardless of the compliments
coming from mcaro so ya know I mean it
really was an exciting day fantastic and
of course a car moving on that is your
semi final match if you will have our
team even so tomorrow with me and Robert
once again on the call but regardless of
what's going on with the speeches
championship and the grand chess to our
finals we also have been reminding
people we already have the puzzle battle
world championship under way in terms of
qualification we've had a lot of videos
submitted top puzzle solvers we already
know the guy the guy I say the guy
because I've referred to him as the guy
I was like who is this guy Jim is 98 but
he submitted a video we're gonna have a
great combination of super strong
players and great puzzle solvers
score 35 in puzzle rush submit the video
on social media using at chess go at us
you know the official Twitter channel of
chess comm or use the hashtag puzzle
battle and we'll pick it up and
qualification videos and December 15 so
get your qualification video in and
maybe you'll be competing for some big
prizes Robert you're not allowed to
submit a qualification because you got
to commentate with me wait I can't
submit one of you can just reject it you
can I'm just gonna reject it yeah that's
okay you know Dikembe Mutombo ah me I'm
a bit hard I mean this got way too
personal all of a sudden so I regret
even asking the question anyway no I
want to touch him one thing and you
really were right that it was nice to
hear do to talk about the psychology of
once you're up how he changed his
strategy right I think that's
educational and instructive for
everybody because it when you don't have
the right emotional state of being and
you were like I'm supposed to be losing
in this match and now now I'm over
trying to be perfect right I think that
was a big thing and ultimately losing
that critical game to let a car come
back it's an it's an interesting
takeaway I like that point so and we've
we've all fallen victim to the
perfectionism right because chess is an
objective game we want to find the
perfect move but then when you're
looking at your clock it will you turn
the left Nick wait a second I have 19
second yet which happened many times and
the car has a minute you're like okay
now I can't find the perfect moves in
these critical situations because I
don't have the time to calculate so you
know very honest response by you on
kristef do too I think it's something he
will work on for future speed chess
championships do it as hikaru nothing
more eluded to the world rapid and blitz
is happening the end of December and I'm
sure young Christoph will be playing
yelling at HaMashiach or Nakamura Magnus
Carlsen all these thought players will
be there and I'm definitely looking
forward to that as well to see how they
compete for a world title well thanks
for everyone that's with us don't go
anywhere we are raiding the official
chest comm coverage of the Grantchester
finals which is in the final blitz game
right now between Magnus Carlsen and
Maxime vache the grop ding Li Ren has
moved on so stick with us go with go
over to the chess comm events channel
bring the hype bring the noise please go
watch leve Rosman and rule improves airs
as they covered the final blitz game
between Magnus and fel on behalf of
everybody here Dani wrench Robert has my
producer everybody we out every
buddy see tomorrow with more SEC
coverage
[Music]